hey everyone welcome to the advanced
computer vision course
in this course we are going to learn
advanced techniques
to better our skills of computer vision
now you might think that
the term advance might not be for you
now this does not mean that the topics
are very difficult
it just means that they are on an
advanced level
and we will do our best to learn it as
simple as possible
we will break it down into basic code
and then we will create modules out of
this so that we can
use them in different projects once we
are done
and we will be learning four different
chapters including
hand tracking pose estimation face
detection
and face mesh and not just that we will
also be
creating five different projects so that
we can learn
some real world applications for example
volume gesture control
ai trainer ai mouse control and a lot
more if you would like to see more of
such content
do check out my channel muchas workshop
where we create
projects related to computer vision
artificial intelligence and robotics
so without further ado let's get started
hey everyone welcome to my channel in
this video we will learn
hand tracking in real time we will first
write
the bare minimum code to run and then
learn how to convert it into a module
so we don't have to write it again and
again for different projects
the best part is we don't have to
configure 100 parameters
along with 20 different installs to make
it run
within 10 to 15 minutes you will have
your model working
the framework we will be using today is
called the
media pipe which is developed by google
they created these amazing models that
allow us to quickly get started with
some of the very fundamental ai problems
such as face detection facial landmarks
hand tracking object detection and quite
a bit more
so we will be covering the rest of these
as well so make sure to subscribe to
keep updated
now the model we are working with today
is the hand tracking
it uses two main modules at the back end
so
one of them is the palm detection and
the other one is
hand landmarks now the palm detection
basically works on complete image and
it basically provides a cropped image of
the hand
from there the hand landmark module
finds 21 different landmarks
on this cropped image of the hand to
train this hand landmark
they manually annotated 30 000 images of
different hands
so that is a lot of work and this is one
of the reasons
it works so well and the best part is
that it is cross-platform and we don't
have to dive deep into the sea of
configurations and installations so
within just two clicks
we will be up and running so let's have
a look at the implementation
so right now i am in pycharm and we are
going to
first create a new project so you can
see that
i have created this hand tracking
project
and we will go to file settings
and we will go to our project then the
interpreter
and we will add so here we are going to
add
our packages so we will write here
opencv
python we will install that
and then we will write media pipe
and we will install that so these are
the only two packages that we will be
needing
so within two clicks we are
ready to start coding so that is
amazing okay so now
we will create a new file
we will call it let's say hand
tracking tracking
minimum so the bare minimum code that is
required to run this
so the first thing we will do we will
write here import cv2
and then we will import media pipe
as mp
and then we will import time so this is
to check the frame rate so first we are
going to create our video object so we
will write here cv2
dot video capture and i'm going to use
my webcam number one
you can use your webcam number zero
so then we will write file true and then
we have
success success
and we have our image is equals to
cap dot read so that will give us our
frame we will write cv2 dot
weight key 1 and we will write cv2 dot
i am show i am show
and we will write here image and
a match and we will write img
so this is basically what we always do
to
run a webcam and what we can do as well
is right here that if
more doing it or we can skip it it's
fine
we don't need to write that we have to
close with the q button
so here we can right click and we can
press the run button
and let's see so there you go this is my
webcam you can see my hand
there you go and we are going to
detect this hand so the first thing we
have to do
is we have to create an object from our
class
hands so here we are going to write now
this is related
to the hand detection modules or the
hand detection model
so later on we will create our own
module so that we can
learn how to use it easily in different
projects
so getting the values of these different
points or the landmarks
is a little bit tricky but we will
create a module so that we can just say
i want uh the point number five of the
hand
so tell me the location so that will
become quite
easy to use in different projects so
first of all
we are going to write here mp hands
is equals to mp.solution
now this is you can say a formality that
you have to
do before you can start
using this model so you will write
mp.solutions.hands
and then we are going to write that we
are going to create an object called
hands
we will write mp hands dot
hands and then inside that we have to
write our parameters
now what are these parameters so let's
go and check them out so we will
click on we will press the control
button and we will
right click on this and it takes us to
that function
so here we can check what exactly
are we getting uh what exactly do we
have to input
so here the first thing is the static
image mode
so static image mode they have this
configuration
where they will track and detect
so if you put this as false then
sometimes it will
detect and sometimes it will track based
on the confidence level
but if you put it as static mode then
the whole time it will do the detection
part
which will make it quite slow so we will
keep it false
so that it detects and if it has a good
tracking
confidence it will keep tracking so this
way it will be much faster
whenever the tracking confidence goes
lower than a certain range
then it will do the uh detection again
so
then you have the maximum number of
hands so here we have two
and then we have the minimum detection
confidence
so this is 50 and then minimum tracking
confidence which is 50
so it means if it goes below 50 percent
it will
do the detection again okay so now that
we know our parameters we can go back
and we can write here false
so actually we are not going to write
anything because these are the default
parameters and they have already given
the default values
so we do not have to change or write
anything here
if we want to we can otherwise we can
skip it as well
so for this instance we are going to
skip and later on
we are going to write whatever we need
so then we are going to go
actually we will need to go back okay so
then here
in the loop we are going to send in our
rgb image
to this object so
here we have to first convert it so we
will write here image
rgb is equals to cv2 dot cvt
color and then we will write our image
y is a double bracket okay we will write
our image then we will write cv2
dot color underscore
bgr to rgb
so this is our idea that we want to
convert it into rgb
because this class or this object
only uses rgb images so we need to
convert that first
so we will write here that our results
results is equals to hands
so we are calling this object dot
process so there is a method inside this
object called
process that will process the frame for
us
and it will give us the results so
that's how simple
this is now all we need to know is how
to extract this information and use it
so after this what we can do is
we can simply display this but at this
point we are not really displaying or
doing anything but i still want to run
it to see if everything is working so
far
so it will be processing it but it will
not display anything for us
so let's try it out
so there you go and now you can see even
though it's processing
the frame rate has not decreased it's uh
it seems real time we will later on
check the exact
uh speed as well the exact frame rate so
don't worry about that
okay so then we are going to
open this object up the
the one that we have received and we are
going to extract the information within
so as we have seen the parameters we can
have multiple hands so what we can do is
we can extract these multiple hands so
we will have to put in a for loop
to check if we have multiple hands or
not
and we have to extract them one by one
now before we do that
we have to make sure that there is
something in the results
so we can print out the results
and we can run it
and it just gives us that it is a media
python solution based
solutions output and if i bring in my
hand
nothing really changes so we need to
know when
something is detected or not so to check
if something is detected or not we can
write here dot
multiple multi underscore
hand underscore and
underscore landmark
landmarks so let's run this
and see what happens so here it says
none
and if i put my hand and there you go so
straight away we are getting some values
so what we will do is we will say that
if
we can remove the print or let's keep
the print we can copy this part
and we can go down and we can write here
if
this is true then
we are going to go in and for
each hand so we can say for each hand
landmark
landmarks let's say in
results dot multi
whatever we wrote here multi-hand
landmarks so you saw that we were
getting some results
so is it of one hand or two hands we
don't know well
we actually know because i just put one
hand but it could be of
multiple hands so here we will have
each hand and then we will get the
information or
extract the information of each hand so
once we do that
we have a method provided by
the media pipe that actually helps us
draw all these
points because there are a lot of them
and we you have almost
how many were there 21 points and
between each points if you want to draw
a line
it will be quite a lot of maths that
would be involved there
so they provided us with the function or
a method for that
so we are going to write that down and
that is basically
mp draw we will call it mp draw is
equals to
mp.solutions so lucian's
dot drawing utilities so
we will write that and now we will use
mp draw
to actually draw it so we will write
here mp draw
and then we are going to write draw
landmarks
and inside that we will give in our
image that we want to draw on
so we don't want to draw on the rgb
image
because we are not displaying the rgb
image we are displaying the
original image bgr so we will write
image and then we are going to write
hand lms so this is
a single hand okay so there could be
multiple hands
this is let's say hand number zero then
there could be hand number one
so this is that single hand so if i run
this now
that should draw the hand for us
let's try it out
and there you go so now you can see it
is drawing the hand for us
and it looks pretty good
so but these are points and i told you
that we could draw
the connections as well so how can we do
that
we can do that by writing here
mp hands
dots and underscore
connections so that is it so we are
using
mp hands dot hand connections and this
will
draw the connections for us so let's try
that out
and there you go so now you can see how
easily
we got our uh what he called
hand position and we got
all the 21 landmarks
if you like the video so far give it a
thumbs up and don't forget to subscribe
so this is good but the problem is we
don't still know
how to use these values so where are
these values how can i
extract and use them so for example if i
want to track one of these positions
to perform a certain task what exactly
can i do
so that is still remaining and we will
learn how to do that
but before we go there i want to do the
frame rates so we are going to write the
fps
so to do that we are going to write here
that our previous time is equals to zero
and our current
time is equals to time
is equals to zero okay so
once we have done that we will go down
here and before we display
we are going to write here
current time is equals to time
dot time and this will give us the
current time
and then our fps will be
one divided by our current time
minus the previous time
previous time okay so then
our previous time will become
the current time so our previous time
will be the current time
so yeah that seems good and
what else can we do can we yeah i think
we should
display it on the screen so that we can
see it rather than
putting it on the console so we can
write here cv2.cv2.put text
and we want to put it on our image we
want to convert it into a string
because it is time so we
are using what do we call fps
fps and we also have to round it because
or should we if we round it it will give
us decimal values we don't want decimal
values for fps we can
just put integer so that will give us
that
and then we can give it a value
the position let's say 10 and 70
and then we can give in our font cb2 dot
font whatever comes first
and then we write
then we write the scale and then
we write the color so let's put purple
or let's put blue whatever let's put
purple
and then we have the uh
i think i missed something i missed a
comma here
okay and then we need to put i think the
scale or the thickness the thickness
let's put as two
or let's put a 3. okay
so that seems good
and what else i think that should be
fine let's run it
so here we have it so
now we can see that the time is around
30 30 fps the frame rate it goes to 20
sometimes but most of the times it's 30.
you can see it's quite fast very
responsive
thumbs up oh thumbs up makes it go away
thumbs up yeah this time it worked
thumbs up great let me try my other hand
as well
so that seems fine and it is working
quite good
so we can move on so now we are going to
get
the information within this hand so for
each of these hands so we will get the
id number
and we will also get the landmark
information
so the landmark information will give us
the x and y coordinates
and we also have their id numbers
and they are already listed in the
correct order
so all we have to do is we have to check
their index number
and that's it so what we can do is
we can write here for id
and the landmark we are going to
find it or we are going to enumerate and
then we are going to find it
inside the hand
lms dot landmark
so this is basically our landmark
uh this is basically our landmark that
we are getting
from here and this is the id number or
the index number
that we are getting which will relate to
the exact index number
of our finger landmarks so if it is zero
it will be the bottom
middle one uh then if it's four it will
be a tip
and things like that so what we can do
is we can print here
and we can write id and landmark
so we can see at least what is happening
so let's run that
and there you go so let's see what did
we get
so if we go up here you can see that
this is id number 20
19 18. so if we keep going back
we keep going back we will start from
zero so
each id has a corresponding
landmark and the landmark has x
y and said so we are going to use the x
and y coordinates to find the
information or to find the location for
the landmark
on the hand but the thing is if you see
here these values are decimal places
so the location should be in pixels so
it should be for example
500 pixels in the width and 200 pixels
in the height
something like that but here you can see
these are picks these are
decimal places so basically what they
are giving is they are giving a ratio of
the image
so we will multiply it with the width
and the height and then
we will get the pixel value so this is
how we can get it directly
so here what we are going to do we are
going to first check out
the heights the width
and the channels of our image
which will be which will be
image dot shape
so we can write this and this will give
us the width and height
and then what we can do is we can
find the position so we can write here
cx
and cy is our position of the center
and basically it will be an
integer because it is decimal places so
we have to convert it into integer
so we will multiply our landmark
dot x value multiplied by the width
and for the second one it will be
integer
and then landmark dot y value
multiplied by the height so this will
give us the
cx and the cy position
so now we can print this out but the
thing is
that it is not for a specific one
it is for all of them so if we print it
now let's remove this
and we will print we will print
cx and cy
so if we run this now it will give us
for all 21 values
so how do we know which one is for which
which one
is for landmark one which one is for
landmark two
so we need to write the id of that as
well
so we can write it like this so there
you go
so now we have this information
so if we look here
this is the this is the
id number and this is the cx and the cy
position
so what we can do is we can use any of
these
to actually uh use it to our benefit to
actually print out
any of these landmarks so i can write
here if
id is equals to zero
this means we are talking about the
first landmark
then we are going to let's say draw the
circle
so we will write here cv2 dot circle we
are
drawing it on the previous one and we
will color it a different way and we
will make it a little bit bigger
so it is easier for us to know that this
is the one that we are
printing so it shouldn't be an issue so
we can write here that our radius is
let's say 5
and then our color will be different it
will be purple
and then we have cv2 dot filled
so once we have that now
it will only draw for what do you call
the id number one so if i run this now
and there you go so you can see here at
the bottom
you get okay let me make it bigger it's
very small
so let's make it 25.
there you go so now you can see clearly
that we are detecting that landmark
which is zero
so if i remember correctly four is also
four is a tip of one of the fingers
let's make it 15 25 is too big
there you go so it is the tip of the
thumb so you can see now we are getting
this information
and what we can do is we can put all of
this in a list
and we can use it to print or we can use
it to
find the location and move around and
do all sort of different things with
this
what we can do is we can also remove
this and then it will draw on all of
them
but that's that's not useful because we
are already drawing on all of them
so here you can see looks quite weird
anyways so that is the basic idea that
this is how you get the
cx and cy information which is basically
for each one of these
and we can put them in a list so that
we can later on uh return this list and
use it to our benefit
if we want to track the index finger the
tip of it
or the bottom part of it whatever we
want to track we can do that
so now that we are done with this we are
going to create a module out of this
so that next time if we are using it in
a project
we don't have to write all of this again
we can simply
ask for the list of these values of
these 21 values of each hand for example
we can say give us for the first hand
give us for the second hand whatever
and then we can simply say okay i need
point number 10 and it will give us the
value of point number 10 which is
let's say at this point it is 4 four
four and two one zero
so that will make it very easy for us to
uh create new projects
so let's see how we can do that so now
we will create a modules file
so here we will call its
hand tracking module
so we will copy pretty much all of this
code
and we will paste it here
first of all we will write here
if name
is equals to main
this means that if we are running this
script
then do this so whatever we write in the
main parts
will be like a dummy code that will be
used
to showcase what can this module do
so we will write here def main
and we are going to put our while loop
inside of this
so while true
and in fact all of this as well
uh not that let's copy this part first
so we'll put this here and then this
part here
also for the frames
fps we will put it down here
and what else what else do we need
yeah the video capture
we can put it here
wait why did it show here okay i think i
copied it or what
yeah so we need to remove this
okay and then
what else what else i think that is fine
for now
so now what we have to do
we have to create our class so i thought
of doing it in
functional programming but i think it
will be better if we create a class
so we are going to create a class here
we will call it class
and detector
and inside that we will write def
inits in itself
and inside that we have to give in our
parameters
so these parameters are the basic
parameters
that are required for this hands
so if you remember we went to the hand
and we have
all these parameters so these are the
ones that we will be using
to input that so so that we have the
flexibility of changing these
so here we have the mode so we will
write here
mode is equals to false
then we are going to write the max
number of hands
so we can write here max
hands is equals to 2.
then we can write the
detection the direction confidence
is equals to 0.5 and the
track confidence is equals to
0.5
so then we can remove all of this
and now the first thing we have to do is
we have to write
self dot mode is equals to
mode this means that we are going to
create an object
and the object will have its own
variable
so this is that variable whenever we are
using the
variable of the object we will call it
self dot
something and we are assigning it
initially we are assigning it a value
provided by the user
so we are calling uh we are calling it
mode and we are providing it the value
of the mode
so the same thing we have to do with the
other parameters so we will write here
max
hands is equals to max hands
self dot detection
confidence is equals to detection
confidence self
dot tracking confidence
track confidence is equals to
track confidence and then all of these
have to be inside this initialization as
well
so if you remember they are part
of the initial code where we are
initializing everything and then there
is the while loop
so we need to initialize these as well
over here
and again we will write here self dots
so we will keep putting self dot
everywhere
and we also have to so
why is this giving an error empty hands
because we need to add the self here as
well
so we will write here self.mphands.hands
so that should be good
and inside that we have to give in our
parameters
so the parameters will be self
mode then the max
hands
the confidence
and the tracking confidence
there you go so this should be fine
so i think the initialization is done
so now we can move on to the uh
detection part so we can write here
let's say we will call it
find hands
and inside that we have to just copy
this part so
do we need to convert we do need to
convert
and we need to put this as well so we
will put all of this
we will put it here inside
and then we will go back up here
and let's start from here so first of
all we will need an image
to find the hands-on so that will be
this image
and then hands is not being recognized
because it has to be self-taught hands
so we are talking about this object
within this
uh object so
then we have mp.draw so
this should be self.mp draw and then
self dot
hands connection so that should be good
and should we draw it inside
i i don't think we need to draw it here
in fact we do not even need to get the
landmarks
from here what we can do is we can keep
this outside
and we can comment this
so here this is what we need basically
to draw the hands
so we can put a flag here we can write
here
draw and we can put it
by default as true
and we can check if we want to draw or
not so here we can write here if draw
then do this
okay so it will only draw if we
ask it to draw so i think this is
good enough to actually run the
code or the run the class without
actually getting the list so for testing
this should be fine
so what we can do here so we will create
a new
method within this class that will
find the position for us it will give
that
list for us but for now we will just
test
to see everything is working so far or
not
so here we will first create our object
we will call it detector
is equals to hand detector
and we will not give in any parameters
because we know that
we have these default parameters already
there
so once that is done we will get our
image
and once we get the image we are going
to send this image
we are going to write here detector
dot now this is the method here find
hands
so this is the method within our class
so we will write here find hands and we
have to give in our image
so that is the most important component
so we might need to draw on it so we
need to return the image
if we have drawn on it so we will return
the image so then we can go back
and take the image over here so image is
equals to
this so if we run this now as a module
it should work
so let's see if we did any mistake
uh yeah it's working
oh yeah that's good so
now our module is running because the
main reason for creating this module
is to get those position values of the
landmarks very easily
so we need to create that find position
function
or the method so we will write here find
position and
we are going to give in the parameters
of our image
now we don't really need the parameter
of the image but we need it for the
width and the height so if you remember
here we need the shape
so we can do it in other ways but this
is simple
so we will try it now later we can
improve on it
then we need the hand number so if you
are detecting with
if you want the information of hand
number one hand number two and number
three
whichever hand you want you can ask the
information of that
and then we will have the parameter for
draw
so again we will put it as true by
default
so now we can uncomment this and we can
bring it back
okay so that should work now
here the issue is that we were using a
for loop
to actually run this but now we need to
first check again
we will go back here and we will create
a list here
lm this is the landmark list
that we are going to return so this list
will have all the landmark positions
so we can return this whether it is
filled or not we will return it
so we will return this and then we are
going to
check again that whether any landmarks
were detected or not
or any hands were detected or not so to
do this we use
basically this part here so
if the self results multi-hand landmarks
if that is available then we are going
to
check the next things so here we will
write this
and we will put all of this inside that
so but here we are getting the results
this is
the results it should be self.results
self.results and now i can use
the results here as well okay
so now we need to replace this here as
well
okay so if it's not self then i cannot
use it in this method
to use it in all the methods you have to
make sure
this is for this object
this variable okay so
now we have to write down that
which hand are we talking about because
earlier we were getting it for all the
hands
so if you want you can get it for all
hands it's up to you
but i'm creating this method to get the
uh to get for one particular hand if you
want you can change that too
so here we are going to write so earlier
we had four
hands this this this now we will get
this
and we will point to we will point to
a particular number and that number will
be the
hand number so we will say
that our let's say
our hand let's say we'll call it my hand
is equals to this and we will put this
over here so it will get
the first elements the first hand and
then within that hand
it will get all the landmarks and it
will put them in a list
so here we are just printing them out so
here we can write
uh lm lists list
dot append and we want to append
the values of id cx
and cy
and we can remove the print because
we're getting it anyways
so yeah so that is
i think that is good and here we have
the option
of draw as well so we can write here
if draw then do this
otherwise don't so by default it is true
so it is going to draw
so yeah let's see how that works out so
we can return this list
so i can call this
so we can go down here and i can call
find
position and we can remove the self
and we have the image and do we need
anything
else i don't think so
okay copying this was a bad idea anyway
so
finding positions of image yeah
and it will give us the list so we can
copy this and we can paste here
so now what i can do is by the way we
have to write detector dot find position
so now what i can do is i can print the
value
of my list at any index
so if i want let's say
uh the zero index then i will write here
zero
if i want the landmark number four i
will write here four
so if you remember the 4 was the tip of
the thumb
so this will give us that position so
let's run this and see what happens
index is out of range okay so that is uh
understandable
why because here we have to check
if nothing is found which means lm list
the length of it is zero so we will
write here
that the length of this list is zero
then we will if it's not equals to zero
then we will print
so let's run it again
and there you go so if i put my hands
so now you can see it's drawing for all
of them
but it is showing me only landmark
number four
so if if you look at my thumb so if you
look at my thumb
if i'm going really to the okay it's not
moving the values
okay so now if i go
till the very end you can see it is 600
something because
the value is 640 the max value
and now if i go around to the starting
point
it goes uh around
150 something
so i'm talking about the x position by
the way so the x position is changing
like this then we have the y position
here it is going towards zero and down
here
if we go down here it is going towards
400 something
so this is a 640 by 480 image
it works well with 1280 and 720 as well
so it's still around 20 something frames
per second
so that is quite good okay so now this
is
working as a module and what we can do
is
we can use this in a different project
now you might say
how can we do that well here is the
dummy code
so this dummy code we can use to
actually
uh run in a different project so i can
copy this
and i can create let's say
my new game
game hand tracking
blah blah blah okay that's a very long
name
um so i can i can paste this here
uh the complete code and i can
remove the indentation and then
i can import i can import these
so then i need to check what is missing
so here now i need to imports
i will import hand tracking module
and tracking module as
h t m
so now i will write htm
dot hand detector and the rest will
remain the same
so that is pretty much it so if i run
this now
it should run exactly the same
so there you have it and there you go
so now it's giving me the values of the
index
uh not the index the tip of the thumb
which is
uh landmark number four and it is
showing me all the landmarks
uh as we have drawn so if i if i go back
here
if you like the video so far give it a
thumbs up and don't forget to subscribe
to my module i can change the color or i
can change the size of these as well
again all these parameters you can
change you can add to your methods
if you wish and it could become easier
for you it
depends on your project so if you have a
lot of different
things that you want to accomplish
within one project
then you can add more methods to this
to compensate for that so here let's say
we will make it a little bit smaller
so 15 is too big we will make it seven
let's say
and let's change the color so it's bgr
so let's make it blue
and there you go so now we have changed
it
and if we go back actually i preferred
the previous one
even in the big aspect so um
here what we can do is if you don't want
to show it
we can write here false
and it will not display
oh it's displaying wait why is it
displaying
so why is it displaying let's go back
here and if draw
then only we do this
okay maybe it's drawing here as well
am i running this
yeah i'm running the correct file but
when i write
false here
oh there are more arguments that's the
problem
there are more arguments so we cannot
just write here we have to write draw is
equals to false
my bad straw is equals to false
and there you go the drawing is gone
that the custom drawing that we did
now if you want to remove this drawing
as well you can write here
draw is equals to false
and there you go so now you will see
that you are getting the value of the
thumb
but nothing has been drawn so this way
you can uh customize it to your needs
hey everyone welcome to my channel in
this video we will learn
pose estimation we will detect 33
different landmarks within a human body
and all of this will be done in real
time that's right
more than 24 frames per second and only
running
cpu we will first look into the basic
code required
and then we will create a module out of
this so that we don't have to write the
code again and again
and yes we will be creating a lot of
projects with this
so don't forget to subscribe and hit
that like button
so here we are in our pycharm project
and you can see that we have
named it pose estimation project and we
have a folder here
with post videos so if i open this
up you can see that
we have a lot of different types of
videos
we have a total of nine videos so let me
play a few
so here you can see
this one is a little bit smaller
and some of these videos are actually
slow motion so
when we are running it it will look like
it's slow but it's not actually slow
it's actually slow motion
so like this video and then i think
well i think this video as well it's
slow motion
and i think this one is fine
this one is normal this one is slo-mo as
well
so i took these videos i think from
pixels.com
so we are going to test these videos out
and see how well does our
pose estimation work so we will select
all of this
or let's let's create a new file let's
delete this one
so let's delete this and now we are
going to create
a new file and we will write here pose
as the mason uh minimum
so this is the bare minimum code that is
required to run it
and later on we are going to see how we
can create a module out of this
so that we don't have to write the code
again and again for
a lot of different projects so let's
start
by importing cv2 and then
importing media
pipe as mp
but now you can see that we get an error
this is because we did not
include these packages in our project so
how can we include those
so we will go to file settings and we
will go to
our project interpreter and open that up
and here we will write opencv dash
python and we will hit install
and then we will write media pipe
and we will hit install so now both the
packages have been
installed and we can go back and you can
see the error is now
gone so opencv is the library that we
will be using for image processing
and media pipe is the framework that
will allow us to
get our pose estimation so
now the first thing we will do we will
read our video
so we will write here cap is equals to
cv2 dot video capture and we will simply
give in
our video number so here we will write
pose
videos videos
and we will write video number one
dot mp4 i think the one
is quite big let's let's try it out and
later we can change it if we want
and then we will write while true
and we will write success and
image is equals to cap dot read
so that will give it our image and then
we can write here cv2 dot i am show
and we will write here image image and
then we will write here
image and then we will write cv2 dot
weight key and we will write one so that
we get
a one millisecond delay okay so let's
run this and see if it works
and there we have it so our video went
quite
fast so the frame rate
is actually quite high at this point
what we can do is we can check the frame
rate by writing here
time let's say
current time is equals to uh we need to
import time as well so we will write
here import time
and then we will write time dot
time then we will write
that our fps is equals to
1 divided by
our current time minus
our previous time and our previous time
is equals to current time and we need to
define the previous time
up here at the top so we'll write here
previous time
is equals to zero and then we can simply
put our text so we will write here put
cv2 dot put text and we will write in
our image
and then we will write in the text
itself
so we will write string fps
but we will convert it into an integer
before we do that
then after that we have our origin so
let's say
70 and 50 and let's say
the cv2 dot font
plane and let's say uh
three and then for the color we can put
two five five zero and two five
and zero and then we can put three
so this should give us our frame rate
let's try that out
uh wait what happened okay
this should be below over here my bad
so let's run it again
and there we have it so you can see it's
a hundred something frames
per second so that's quite a lot if you
want to reduce it we can put here let's
say 10
so now it's like 50 60 frames per second
but when we are using our model it will
automatically slow it down so we don't
need to worry about that
so the next step would be to
create our model so our objects so that
we can
detect our pose so here we are going to
write
mp pose pose is equals to
mp dot solutions so solutions
dot pose so we are going to use this
and then we are going to create our
object we are going to say pose is
equals to
mp pose mp pose
dot pose and then we will give in our
parameters
so if we go to the parameters you can
see that we have the static image mode
this is basically that when you are
detecting and when you are tracking so
if you put it as true
then it will always detect based on the
model
it will always try to find the new
detections
but when you put it as false it will try
to detect
and when the confidence is high it will
keep tracking
so there will be a tracking confidence
and then there will be a detection
confidence
so whenever it detects if the confidence
is more than 0.5
it will say okay now we have detected
now i will go to tracking
now the tracking will check if the
tracking confidence is
more than 0.5 it will keep tracking
whenever it goes
below 0.5 then it will come back to
detection so this way we do not use
the heavy model again and again for
detection instead we use detection then
tracking then whenever it's lost
we use the detection again so this is
what this does
and then we have the upper body only so
you can decide if you want to detect
only the
upper part so it will have you can see
here
we have 33 poses landmarks or only 25
so it's up to you which one do you want
to use and here
we also have a feature to smooth which
is
by default true so we will keep it as
true so we can define
all of these parameters or we can skip
them it's up to us
so for the initial purposes we are going
to skip all of these
for the simplicity so then we
are going to go down here
and simply we are going to convert our
image so we will say image
rgb is equals to cv2 dot
cvt color so this image is in bgr
but this library or this framework
uses rgb so to
make it compatible we have to convert it
so we will write here image and then we
will write cv2
dot cv2 dot
what color underscore
bgr to rgb
so this is our conversion and once we
have done the conversion we are simply
going to send this image
to our model so we will write here
results
is equals to pose dot
process and we will write image
rgb so that's pretty much it
so that will give us our uh detection
of our pose but it will not draw
anything
but for now we can just run it to see
if everything is working and now you can
see that the frame rate has decreased
so this is good to see that our model is
actually working
but you can see that it's almost uh real
time
so that is really good so now what we
can do is
we can draw our landmarks or whatever we
have detected we can draw it
but before we do that we can print the
results as well so we can write here
results
and let's see what do we get so here you
can see we get nothing
so it's just a class but we don't see
any information
so how do we see the information we
simply write
results dot pose
landmarks land
marks so if we run that
now you will see that we are getting
actual landmarks
so each landmark will have the x y
and z value and then it will also have a
visibility value
so how visible is it so this
is the information that we get so we can
put all of this in a list later on so
that it's easier to access
so then we will check if it is detected
or not so we will say that
if this is present
if this is true then we are going to
write here
that mp draw
dot draw landmarks draw
underscore landmarks
and then we are going to define our
parameters but here you can see we don't
have anything called
mp draw so we are going to declare that
we will write here mp draw
draw is equals to mp.solutions
solutions dot draw utilities so
we will use that and then we can write
here uh
within our landmarks we can send in our
image
then we can write results dot
uh pose landmark so this is the same
thing that we are printing out that we
got
so we will write here land marks and
then what do we have uh i think that is
good
let's do that let's run it
and there you go so now you can see we
are getting all the points
you can see that it is in red now what
we can do is we can also add the
connections
or the lines between these so here we
can write
mp dot not mp pose
dot pose connections
so that will fill up the connections
there you go so now you can see we have
the green lines which are the
connections
and then we have the points as well and
we are
detecting them all at real time so that
is
very very amazing so
now we know that we are getting this
information
but how can we know which is for which
so here it just says landmark this
landmark this
there is no indication of which landmark
represents what
so what we need to do is we need to
organize a little bit
so that it is in a list and we can
simply
use these values um in our project so
for example i will say
i want landmark number five i want
landmark number three
so if we go to the media pipe website
you can see here that these are the
landmarks that they have given
so for example if i want the right ear
so i can just say i want the element
number five element number eight
so give me that element if i want the
nose i can say
give me the element number zero so based
on this it will become very easy for us
to actually uh create our new projects
so gesture recognition and
lots of different applications will
become very very easy
so how can we extract the information
within
this object so what we can do is we can
write here
for id and landmark
in enumerate
we will write this result so we are
going to loop through this
and we want the count as well that's why
we have written enumerate
so it will give us the loop count over
here so 0
1 2 3 and so on then we are going to
get the shape actually this will be
we have to add here landmarks
landmark and
then we are going to write here height
width and channel is equals to img
dot shape and the reason we need this
shape
is because uh let me actually show you
why and you will understand
so what we can do is we can write here
print and we can write
lm dot x
or let's just print lm so you can see
what is happening
and we can print the id number as well
so you know
what exactly are we extracting here so
let's run this
so there you go so now you can see we
have the id number and this is the
information of the landmarks so 30
is this 21 is this
and it goes all the way to wait why is
this showing
i think i didn't remove the other print
anyways so you can see here from 0 to
32 we will have all these 33 landmarks
so let's go down
and let's just remove the previous print
first
okay so now we know that we have the id
and we have the landmark
but you can see the landmarks they are
actually in decimal places
so this is basically a ratio of the
image
so what we can do is to get the actual
pixel value
we can say that lm dot x
this will give us this x value
multiplied by
the width of the image so that will give
us the
uh x of our what do you call
the point or the landmark so it will
give us the exact pixel value
the same thing we can do for lm dots
y and we can multiply it with the height
so we can do that and then what we can
do is we can put them
in our cx and cy variables
so this way it will be easy for us to
use
the indentation is wrong that is why
it's giving an error
okay so also we need to convert this
into integer because
we have to make sure it's not a float or
a double
because we are talking about pixel
values so then what we can do is to
confirm that this is happening and we
are getting the correct values
we can simply print the circle uh on top
of this point so we can write here cv2
dot circle and in the circle we will
write
image and then we will write cx
and cy and then we can write
let's say the value of 15 15 will be too
big
let's say 10 then 2 5 5
0 2 5 5 this is purple
let's make it blue and then we will
write
cv2 dot filled
so this will overlay on the previous
points
if we are detecting it properly so let's
try it out so there you go
so now you can see we have those blue
dots and
these are the ones that we put ourselves
so this means that we are getting the
correct information at the correct pixel
values and it is working good
we can reduce this to five
there you go much better actually let's
try another video we have been using the
same video we have like
nine videos so let's try a random one
number five yeah that looks good
let's try number six
yep that is good number
three
there you go okay here we had an issue
but now it's fine
that's good so we can see that we are
getting good results
and that should be good enough for us so
next what we can do is we can convert
this into a module
so that we can use these values very
easily
so the first thing we will do we will go
here and right click
and we will create our module let's call
it
pose module
and we will copy all of the bare minimum
code
and we will paste it here so
that looks good now the first thing
to make it a module we have to write
here
if underscore underscore name
is equals to underscore underscore
main then we are going to write
main so what this does is that if we are
running this
by itself then it will run the main
function
and if we are just calling another
function
it will not run this part so this is
what it means
so we will write here
main and within the main we are going to
write everything
or we will write the dummy code in the
main so whenever you want to see
what a module is capable of or the
testing script
you can put it in the main function so
here
we will we will take this
till here we will cancel it from here we
will cut it
and we will paste it in the main
then we will take all of this as well
we will cut it and paste it in the main
again
so that should be
good and what else
so now we are going to create a class
so in that class what we should be able
to do is
we should be able to create objects and
we should be able to have
methods that will allow us to detect the
pose
and find all these points for us
okay so here we are going to say
that our class let's say is pose
detector
and inside that we will have our first
method
which is the init this is the
initialization
so we will write here in itself and
then we are going to write in the
parameters
that are required so whatever parameters
we are expecting we will write here
so here we are going to write mode so if
i go to
where is it okay let's go to pause
estimation
and here we are going to go to
pose so i will copy all these parameters
and we will just paste them here
and we will write so the first one is
mode so we will keep it as
false so that we get fast detections
uh fast detection plus tracking and then
we
will write here upper body so upper body
is equals to false and
then we have the smoothness
smooth is equals to true and
then we have the the
detection confidence is equals to 0.5
and then we have the tracking confidence
is equals to
0.5 so these will be our initial
parameters
and then we can remove this and then we
can
write here that self self
dot mode is equals to mode now if you
are not familiar with
object oriented programming then this
basically means
that uh whenever we create a new object
it will have its own variables
so this whenever you write self dot
something
it is the variable of that object so
whenever we are using
um a variable within our class
we will uh write self dot something
so self dot objects uh sorry self dot
mode
dot self.upbody so we are going to write
that so here we are saying
that the specific variable of our
class or our object is basically the one
that the user has provided so it will
set
this instance of that object to false
so this is what it does so here we will
copy all of these
and we will write up body is equals to
up body and then we will write smooth
is equals to smooth and then we will
write
detection confidence is equals to
detection confidence
and we will write track confidence is
equals to track confidence
so as i mentioned before we just have to
put self dot
in front of each one of these and that
should be good to go
so next we also have to declare these
so again this will be part of that
object
so we need to write self so here we will
write
self.draw self.impose and
self.pose and we will write here
self dot impose
so this is good and what we can do is
earlier we were not using any of these
parameters but now we have to
so here we are going to send in all the
parameters so we will write yourself
that mode
so self.body
self.smooth
self thought detection confidence
and self-taught tracking confidence
so that is pretty much it okay we need
to put a comma here
and yeah so our initialization is pretty
much
done and now what we can do is
we can uh create a method to find the
pose
so we can write here find pose
and we do have to write self here so
whenever we are creating a new method we
have to write cell first
and then we have to give in our image
and then we will also have
a flag called draw and we will put it as
true
so this basically what it will do is it
will ask
the user do you want to draw or not do
you want to display it on the image or
not
so we want to we want to display so we
are going to put this
inside here and
then uh
this draw if results draw this this this
yeah this will be separate this for loop
will be separate
and this results will be here so let's
push this in and we can remove this
and what else so now we need to
write the self dot so here we will write
self dot pose
process and self dot mp draw
then we can also write
self.mppos
so anything missing
no it seems fine now what we need to do
is we need to put
that flag so we will write here if draw
then we basically do this
so that should be good
so let's try it out
or should we put it inside let's put it
inside that
so we will say that if landmarks are
present
or let's put the draw inside
so if the landmarks are detected and we
set draw
then you need to draw
so that is good so
by now we should have a working class
so we can create an object from it and
then we can run it so let's try that out
so here we will write our detector
detector is equals to
our pose detector
and we will give in the default
parameters and here what is happening
here
this should be inside the while loop so
here we are going to write
detector dots find
what was it find or
find pause
why is it not detecting
oh the indentation is wrong
so now it will detect okay so detector
dots
find pose and then we have to give in
our image so that should be it
and we need to return the image so we
will write here
return image
and we can bring in the image back
so if we run this it should draw
on our video so let's run the pose
module
and there you go so now it is running
and it looks good
let's try it on the first image
there you go so this is quite good
and what we can do next is we can do the
main part which is to
find the points so we need to get those
points here we are going to define
the get position
and we will write inside that we want
an image and then again we want the draw
flag so by default we are going to
yeah let's put it as true and then we
can
uncomment this
okay so now what we will do is
we will first of all here we are getting
an error for result
because we need to write self dot
results
here and here
and here and here
okay so that should be good and what
else so we need to push this
in in the for loop so now
we are we are just looping we need to
check first as well
if the results are available so if the
results are available
then we will use this for loop
and then
we need to put it in a list so
we are going to write a list lm list
which is for our landmarks
and we will append our values so here it
depends on you
what kind of values do you want to
append so i'm going to append
only the x and y values and the id
if you want to append the z and the
uh what was the other one the visibility
you can do that too so here i will write
lmlist dot append
and i will write in the id
so here i will write id and
then i will write the
cx and the cy
and i will add the option here
that if draw
then do this
so this looks pretty good so let's go
down
and try it out so where is it
here so we can write here that our lm
list
is equals to detector
dot find position
is it find position or get position
let's keep it find position so it's
similar to the previous one find
position
find position and then we will give in
our image
and let's keep it as true for drawing so
we know it is detecting
and we can print out the list as well so
we can print
out lm list
and there you go so now you can see we
are wait why is it printing this
that is not right
uh okay this is printing this parts
any other prints
uh no so let's write again
yeah so right now it's none wait why is
it none
the lm list is none
lm list oh we didn't return it
forgot to return return lm list
okay so now we can run it and there you
go so now we have the list
and if we go till the end you will see
we have a total of 32 points
so we have 33 points because we are
starting from zero
so now i can easily say for example i
want
number zero i want number eight i want
number five
number twenty three whatever i want i
can write down here
so let's say we want number eights
or let's say we want number 14.
let's try that number 14.
there we have it so this is the number
14 and if i wanted to
i could draw this number 14 so i can
i can put this as draw
false and then here
i can write uh lm14
at one and two so this will be
one and this will be
two and i can make this really big
so i can see what exactly i'm am i
tracking and i can change the color of
it
so that it is a little bit different
than all of these so i can put it as red
and there you go so now you can see
we are tracking this elbow so this is
how
easy it can be uh by the way whenever it
finishes the video it will give you an
error
you can loop through that there's a
function for that as well but we're not
going to do that
so this is the basic idea of how you can
convert this into a module
and now you can use this in any project
that you want and you can easily find
the position
so how exactly can you do that so let's
create a new file
and we will call this our
awesome pose projects
so we will copy the parts
from the main so as i said this is the
testing code
so we will copy all of that and we will
paste it in our awesome project
and now we have to import so we will
write here
import cv2
and then we have to import
time and then we have to import
our module so our module needs to be
in the same folder if it's not in the
same folder it will not work
so you have to write import pos module
as pm because
it's a smaller name so we can write here
pm dot
pose detector so this will create the
detector and everything else will run
the same way
so if we run this now our awesome
projects
and you can see it runs exactly the same
way
so now i can use this in many different
applications
so one thing we can do is we can test
some other videos so
let's say number two
there you go again we are detecting the
right elbow
and you can see it's tracking really
well that's pretty awesome
even when it's a little bit hidden it's
still tracking it
that's really good and then let's try
number three
what happened to number three
there's an error list
index out of frame okay so yeah this
is a problem because we are not checking
uh
if the list if actually the list is
filled or not so we need to check
if lmlist
is not equals to zero actually the
length of it
is not equal to zero if the length of
this is not equals to zero then only we
can do these two things
so actually we should change that at the
main module as well so where is it
here
so let's run the awesome project again
and this time it works
so probably the first frame it was not
able to detect that's why it was giving
this error
so now you can see it's detecting that
elbow let's try number four
there you go detecting the right elbow
very nicely
let's try number five
there we have it excellent the frame
rate is amazing
so you're getting real time number six
pretty good and the best part is it's
running on cpu it's not actually using
gpu to run this
so that is very good then we have number
eights
let's try that
okay that looks good
and then we have number nine
so yeah that is pretty good so
there are a few instances where
it gets it wrong but overall you can see
it's really good
hey everyone welcome to my channel in
this video we are going to learn the
latest face and eye detection method
that runs at an amazing 60 frames per
second
and all of this on an hd resolution this
is a lightweight model
provided by google so it runs on cpu
and mobile devices as well
so here we are in our pycharm project
and the first thing we will do
we'll go to file settings and
we will go to our project and the
interpreter and we will add
so here we are going to add opencv dash
python and we will also
install media pipe
which is the library that will help us
detect
faces okay so now both of them are
installed
and here on the side you can see that
our project is called
face detection project and then we have
a folder called videos
so let's open that up and see what it
contains
so here is the folder and we have
a total of six videos that we are going
to test on
now you could do it on a webcam as well
but i'm going to do it on a video
because one it will be more clear
and second with the webcam you will have
a limit of the frame rate
so with the videos you will have faster
frame rates
okay so we are going to right click and
we will go to python file
and here we are going to create our
project so
we will call this face detection
basics so the idea is that we are going
to look at the very basics
the bare minimum code that is required
to run it
and once we understand that we are going
to go ahead and create a module out of
this
so that we do not have to write it again
and again for
different projects so the first thing we
will do
is to import cv2 and then import
media pipe as mp this is
so that we don't have to write media
pipe again and again
we can just write mp and then we will
import time
this will be to display the frame rate
so uh first of all we are going to
run our video so we will write here cap
is equals to cv2 dot
video capture and we are going to
capture
from within our video folder so we will
write here video slash
one dot mp4 so this is the video that we
will be using
and then we will write here while
true we are going to
write success and image is equals to
uh cap dot read
so that will give us our frame and then
we are going to write cv2 dot
weight key as one
and we will also write cv2 dot im show
we will write image and then image
so this is pretty much you can see the
boilerplate
of our projects that we have been doing
so
we can simply right click and run this
and we have an issue cb2
uh is it oh it's called videos
it's not video okay
so there you go so this is the video
that we will be using and as you can see
it is going
pretty fast because it is running
at a higher frame rate so you could
reduce the
frame rate from here for example if i
put 10
you will see that the frame rate is
uh it's much closer to real time
but we are not going to do that instead
we are going to display the actual value
so to do that we will simply write here
c time is equals to time
dot time and then we will write
fbs is equals to 1 divided by
our current time minus the previous time
and then we are going to write that our
previous time
is equals to the current time and then
we can display it so we will write cb2
dot put text
we'll put it on our image we are going
to write
fps oh i wrote it wrong
f and then f p s
and then we will write a curly bracket
and inside that we are going to write
integer and then
fbs and what else
then we need to define the position so
let's say 20 and 70.
and then we are going to
write down the font so cb2 dot
font let's take the plain one then we
have
the scale let's put it as three color
let's put it as blue
or green let's put it as blue
uh two five five two five five
zero and two no zero
okay then we will write let's say the
thickness
and yeah that's pretty much it one more
thing we have to do we have to declare
the p
time for the initial frame because it is
not defined before and we are using it
here
so we need to define before that and all
of this
needs to be before the image show
so we are going to put it down here and
we can simply run this
and see what happens there you go so you
can see the frame rate is
extremely high 140s 160s something like
that
um blue might not be the best color so
let's put a screen
let's try that yep that's much better
okay so now that we have our frame rate
by the way uh as i was mentioning before
you can reduce the frame rate from here
let's say i put 20
so now you will see that yeah
it's much closer to real time it's
around 30 something 40.
by the way this video is a slo-mo
so that's why it looks a little bit
slower
because the video itself is a slow
motion video
so if i open it up
and i play this you can see this is
actually a slow motion video
okay um we could use the second one as
well
yeah this one looks real time or
it's hard to tell okay
we could try it with the second one here
let's see how that works out
yeah it's it's not real time either
okay so uh anyways so that's the idea so
we will keep it as one
because we are going to process it and
hopefully we are going to get a good
frame rate
so you can see it's quite fast
so what is the next step
the next step is to import our media
pipe
functions or classes so that we can use
them
so here what we will do is we will use
the face detection module
so we will write here mp face detection
phase detection is equals to
mp dot solutions
dot face detection
detection yeah
okay so then we need something to draw
now we can draw ourselves as well
but we can import the drawing part here
as well let's say mp
draw is equals to mp.solutions
solutions
and then draw drawing utilities
okay so basically this will allow us to
draw without
going into the details but if we want to
draw ourselves we can do that too
because the rectangle drawing a
rectangle should not be that hard but we
are getting
a few points as well we will be getting
six points
so for the eyes and the nose and the
ears
so we could we could simply draw them by
using this
okay then we are going to write phase
detection
is equals to uh mp face mp
face detection dot face detection
so this basically initializes that we
are going to use a face detection
again my spellings are wrong to fix that
okay so then we can simply go
and this is an bgr image so we need to
convert it
into rgb before we do that before we
send it
to the media pipe library
so we will write here image rgb is
equals to cv2
dot cvt color and we will give in our
image and then we will write cv2 dots
color underscore bgr
to rgb to rgb
okay so then we will write here that our
results
is equals to face detection
dot process and we want to process our
rgb
image so this is the idea whatever
the the output is it will be stored in
the results
and then we can process these results so
we can print this
out we can write here results and
let's try it and see what happens
there you go so now all of a sudden you
have seen that the
frame rate has decreased so if i don't
run this
and i don't print this you will see that
the frame rate is very high
but as soon as i run it
the frame rate reduces to around 60
70 i can even see 90s
so yeah so it means it's working at the
back end and it is giving us a
class so they have their own class by
media pi
python solutions so what we need to do
is we need to know
how to extract the information out of
this
so we are going to do that next
so here we are going to write so it can
be multiple faces
actually let's go to a video let's go to
the first video again because it has
multiple faces
so we will check if the results
dot detections detections
is available then we are going to write
for
id and then detection
detection in
results dot detections
the text sections okay
so we are going to find in that but it
should be
enumerate because we want the
id number as well so we will write this
and then we can loop through each one of
the results and we can
display them so we can write here print
detection
so whatever we have it is being
processed here
and what we can do is we can display it
with the id
so we can write id and then it will show
us the detection
so let's run that
okay there is some issue here
uh where is it
results start again the spellings the
detections okay
so if i close this and if i go up here
you can see these are the key points so
here it is saying
that this is detection number one
this is id number one and they have
given it a label of
zero this is the score this is 91
percent sure that it is a face
then there is location data within it
which means the bounding box
and then there are key points so one two
three four
five and six key points so
you can use these key points as well but
we are more interested
in the face itself so here you can see
this is zero this is face number zero
and this is face number one so the label
id is same because both of them are
faces
and here we have face number one and
here we have face number
zero so now we need to know how to
extract this information
so we already know that this is a class
so what we can do is
we can for example if we wanted the
score we will write detection dot score
so if i write here detection dot
score that will give me the value of the
score
so i can print that out what happened
there
so if i print that out you will see i'm
getting the detection by itself
so separately i'm getting the value so i
can get that
then how can i get the for example the x
minimum
so this is the x y position
that we want so to do that you can see
that we have
first of all location data inside
location data we have relative bounding
box
so we need to write that so we will
write here print
we will say location data first of all
detection
detection dot location data
and then we will write dot
relative bounding box so that should
give us
the values so let's comment these
and let's run this
and there you go so now we simply have
the information of our bounding box
okay so that is good now what else can
we do
now the thing is that these are uh you
can say
normalized values so they are normalized
between zero and one
so what we need to do is we need to
multiply them with the width and the
height
to get the pixel values so we can draw
but before we actually go into the
drawing we can also draw
by the function that they have provided
so that function is mp draw
dot draw landmarks
or draw detection and then
we have image and then we have the
detection
so yeah that should draw
the faces for us there you go so now you
can see we are getting the points and we
are getting the faces
uh the bounding box around the faces now
the thing is
for me the the points are not very
accurate i don't see them being useful
you can see sometimes maybe you will get
a better result
maybe let's say video number two let's
try that
yeah here it's a little bit better you
can see the eyes and the nose
and let's try number three
yeah here for the baby you can see it's
quite good
so again if you want to use the
points then you should make sure that
the video is quite zoomed in
the focus is on the face so if you want
that you can
use the points for the eyes and for the
nose
and for the ears so the same way we got
the information of
the x and y and the score the same way
you would get the information of the
landmarks
but i'm not going to go into the
landmarks i will just keep on the
bounding box we will focus on the
bounding box
and we will also focus on the score so
these three things
are what we are interested in if you
want more you can
add on to it so now that we know
how to draw this uh what we need is
we need to draw ourselves we need to get
the bounding box information
so that if we want to use it um just the
numerical values
we should have access to those so what
we will do is
instead of using all of this so if i
wanted
if i wanted the value of x minimum i
would have to go inside this as well
and i will write x minimum here now that
is a very long call
for just one value so we need to
shorten it so that it is easier to work
with
so what we are going to do is we are
going to store all this information
in a bounding box and from that
we are going to extract these
information we are going to multiply
so what do i mean by that let's have a
look so we will say that our bounding
box
coming from the class is equals to
detection all of this detection dot
local
location data relative bounding box all
of that
so that is the the bounding box coming
from the class
that's why we wrote c in front of it but
then we are going to convert it
in our own language so that we can work
with
pixel values rather than just the
normalized values
so we will call that the simple bounding
box
without the c and what we need to do is
we need to write here
that our bounding box c
dot x minimum multiplied by
our width now but we don't have the
width
so what we will do is we will write up
here
that our image height then our image
width
and our image channels is equals to
image dot
shape and then i can use here i
width image width by the way this i here
is not a big deal because
defining variables is about scope
where is it being used if it is being
used
in a lot of different places it has a
very wide scope
maybe it's being used out of the
function out of the loop
then yes then you need to define long
names that
are clear like here location data
relative bounding box
and what not but if you are using it in
a small scope
for example when you use for loops you
write 4i
in range right so why did you write i
you wrote i because you are not going to
use that i outside this for loop
the scope is very limited so if you are
writing i
w i h or even w h
it's not a big deal so then we are going
to
convert this into integer and
then we are going to copy this
and here we are going to write that we
need
the y minimum and we are going to
multiply this
with the height so that's the idea
and then let's go to the next line so
we'll put a backslash
and then we will copy this and
here we are going to write width
and we will keep it iw and here we will
write
height so now our bounding box will have
x y and width and height so we can
simply use to draw this
uh using a rectangle function or we can
use these values outside
uh in our project so that should be good
so what we can do is
we can write here cv2 dot rectangle
and we will put the image and we will
say the bounding box
we can simply feed in the value because
it contains all the four values it will
understand
and then we will let's make it purple
zero two five five and let's make the
thickness
of two so that
should be enough let's remove this
so note that we are not drawing by
default so we are not using
the default function to draw we are
drawing by ourselves
so let's run that and there you go
so now we are getting a clean box uh
bounding box that is quite nice
there you go you saw here yeah you can
see here we are getting some false
detections as well
um so what you can do is you can you can
change
the uh what you call there there is
a parameter here minimum detection
confidence so you can change this
so you can write here it's by default at
0.5
you can write let's say 0.75 hopefully
that will remove that
there you go so now you don't see the
false positives
okay so that is good
now what else can we do so
this is quite good and
the only thing we might want to see is
the confidence value
so the confidence value or the score as
i mentioned
you can get by detection.score and we
can put it
let's copy this we can put it on the
bounding box
and here we can write for example
that we have let's keep it integer we
have detection
dot score and
we are going to get the first element of
it
uh if you don't get the first element it
it will just put a bracket
around it so it has only one value but
it will put a bracket around it so we
are just removing
that bracket and we can multiply it by
100 so that it is a percentage
and we can write outside that this is a
percentage
and we don't need to write anything at
the beginning
and the location should be bounding box
at 0 b b o x
at 0 and then bounding box i think
that is way too much
okay let's bring that down too so
bounding box
bounding box at one
but we are going to subtract -20 from it
so that um it is easier to see it is not
overlapping with the box
okay so let's run that and see if it
works
there you go so we are getting 90
something percent of uh score
the confidence level so i think it
should be the same color
so it looks blended in
so we will put it here two five five
what else i think the size was big too
so we can change it to two
yeah that looks much better so
let's try out the first video
there you go so that's pretty good
we are able to detects with the score
and with the
bounding box value
so now this is good but the problem is
that you can see that there is quite a
bit of code
that you have to write to find the face
and to get the values that you can use
so what we can do is
instead of initializing and writing all
of this code again and again
for different projects what we will do
is we will create a module out of this
so that we just import that module and
use it whenever we want
okay so how can we do that so we are
going to go to python file and we will
call this
face detection module
and here we are going to copy all of our
basic code
now the first thing for the module we
need is
our if statement so if
we have the name underscore
name is equals to main
so this means that if we are running
this file
then we need to run main so whatever is
in main
is like the dummy code it is kind of a
hint that
this is how you can use this module so
we are going to declare here
that this is main and inside main
we are going to write our while
statements
so so
yeah let's copy this part
we will paste it in the main then
we have the while so we will just read
the frame
and then we have the ending part
we will put the frame rate as well
over here so yeah that should work
fine
then we are going to
okay so then we are going to create our
class so we are going to call this
face the tech tourer
and we are going to define our initial
function
uh initial method in it and
then inside that we are going to write
um okay let's let's leave it for now or
let's write it that's right
minimum detection confidence
the the tech
shun confidence okay that should be fine
and
we will give it a default value of 0.5
now the thing is that we need to put
everything
which is related to initializations over
here
inside so we will take this and we will
put this
in and we will remove some spaces first
of all we need to write here
self dot
minimum detection confidence
is equals to minimum detection
confidence so
in in objects or in the classes all we
need to do is
we need to write here self dot and
here we will write self dot self dot and
self dot
so it is not a generic variable or a
global variable
it is now an instant variable so
whatever we are defining is for this
class
or for this object so that's why we are
writing self
okay so that is good now we need to
define
another function or a method called
find faces
and we need an image do we need anything
else
we can put a flag of draw
so draw is equals to true by default
so we are going to put all of this in
and
let's see what do we need to change
first of all we need to write the self
dot
so here we will write self dot face
detection
and then we will also write self dot
results
self thought results in case we want to
use it later
it's not really required at this point
but anyways
so we will comment this
we can remove all of this
and what else okay so now we need to
return something so we are finding the
faces that is all good
but we need to return all these faces so
what we will do is
we will return the bounding box
information
the id number and also the
score if you want to return the
landmarks you can return that to here
so what we will do is we will create a
new variable
a new list and we will call it bounding
boxes
plural so we will make it empty
and all of this is being done for one
phase
so it is showing and it is processing
face by face
so what we need to do is whenever it
processes we need to put that in our
bounding boxes
so here when we have our bounding box
value
then we can send in whatever we want so
in this case we are going to send
bounding boxes dot append
and we are going to append uh first of
all the bounding box
and then we are going to append the
uh detection dot score
so if you want you can append the id as
well but normally
it is the same what you call
it will have the same list number the
index of the list
so it is a bit redundant but anyways if
you want you can add this too
so this is the idea then we simply
return
these uh bounding boxes so we return
bounding boxes and we also returned the
image
that has all these detections on it
so that is the idea so
by now we should have it running
let's try it out so we are going to
create an object from our class we will
call it the
detector and
we are going to write that our
face detector
we are not going to give in any value so
by default it's 0.5 we will keep it 0.5
so once we get the frame we are going to
write here
image is equals to detector dot
find faces and we will give in our image
and we will keep it the draw as default
so that is good now if we run this it
should pretty much run the same way
as it did before
and there's an error so inside of main
okay so
here we are facing an issue with the
bracket probably
what is it
image this is fine
i think it seems fine to me
let's go here and copy this
yeah it's exactly the same so it should
work
uh the error is not here it's probably
because it's not
finding the image
okay
let's remove this part and try it
yeah it is about the image it's not able
to get
the video why are you not able to get
the video
um are you not able to get
pds1.mp4
okay let's remove this as well
okay i get it my bad there are two
parameters
that needs to be returned so we need to
write here bounding boxes
yeah that was the issue so let's run
this
and there you go now this is the module
yes this is the module running
okay so that is good now it is running
and okay it's not detecting properly
why did we change the
we can we can change the value here
so maybe let's say 0.4
but it was working before yeah here it's
0.75 that's the issue
so we need to put this here
minimum detection uh self dot minimum
detection
okay so that is good now we do not need
to do 0.4 here
it by default at 0.5 so it should work
fine there you go so now
it is detecting properly okay so that is
good
now it is working as a module and we can
get the information by the way you can
just print here
prints the bounding boxes and
let's see what do we get there you go so
now you are getting the information
so this is face number zero this is the
bounding box
this is the confidence this face number
one bounding box and the confidence
so you can extract this information and
use it very easily
so by now we are pretty much done but i
want to do something
else now this is you can say kind of a
fancy thing if you want to do this you
can add it
but it is of course not necessary so
what i want to do is
we are always showing these bounding
boxes
uh the same way we are just drawing a
rectangle and it's very plain
it doesn't look good this is a new
method so i want to show it
in a new way so what can we do so what i
was thinking is
that we can put some corner what do you
call
lines a little bit thicker so that will
give it
um that will give it an image of like a
target
so whenever you have a target you have
these edges that are thicker
and then you have the bounding box in
between something like that
so let's try to add that here
so what i will do is i will create a new
method here
and i will call that um
let's say fancy draw
instead of regular draw we are going to
do fancy draw so we are going to write
here that we need our image
and we need the bounding box
so uh we will do one at a time so just
send
us one bounding box and we will uh put
the bounding box around it
then send the next one and then so on it
will not take
an array okay so then first of all we
are going to
open it up we are going to extract the
information from it
so we are going to write here x y width
and height is equals to the bounding box
and then we also need the
x1 and the y1
which is basically equals to the
diagonal point
so x x and y is the
first point or you can say the origin
point
and then x1 and y1 is the uh
bottom right point so the corner points
at the diagonal position so rather than
calculating it again again we can just
define it
right now so we can write it as x plus
width
and y plus height so now we have all the
information we need
now we can start drawing the lines so
here we will write cv2.line
and inside the line we need to send in
our image
and then we need the starting point so i
will say the starting point is
x and y then we have
the x plus a certain value so this is
the length of that line
so let's write here length is equals to
let's say 30 we will write here length
and then we are going to given the value
of y
so y will stay the same so then we will
give it the color the color
will be the same as the what you call
rectangle so we will write here two five
five zero
two five five and here we have to write
the thickness
so let's write here
that this is the thickness is equals to
let's say 10. so i will write here
uh sorry t
so uh it might be a little bit confusing
at this point but let me show you how it
works
so let's remove this rectangle from here
and i will put this here rectangle
then i will write here
fancy self
dot fancy draw and i will give in the
image
and the bounding box so that's the idea
and it will return the image
so we can write here return image
return image
okay so let's run this and see what
happens
so there you go so now you see there's a
thick line
on the corner now we need to draw the
line at the bottom
so let's draw that so we will copy this
and we will paste it here now this time
around the x
will be without any extra value no
length for the x
we will add the length to the y so if we
run it again
now you see we have a corner point so we
have a corner
we have two lines at the corner so what
we need to do now is we need to
replicate this
on the others uh i think the thickness
for this should be one
we can give it let's say rectangle
thickness is equals to one
and we can put here rt
uh let's run that yeah
this looks much better okay so
and even the thickness for this is too
much let's put it as
seven let's say
yeah it's getting better maybe five
yeah that looks good so next what we can
do is
we can write here that this is for the
top
left which is basically for x and y
okay this is the point x and y then
we will copy this and we will paste it
here and we are going to say that this
is for the top right
and now our position will be x 1
and y so we will just change
this to x one and that should
work fine x one and y
yeah so one more thing is that if i run
this now you will see the
issue it is going outwards we need to
bring it
inwards so how do you bring it inwards
you simply subtract the length
instead of adding in the x direction
so there you go so now it's inwards and
it's done
so we need to do the same for the next
two
so we will copy this and we will paste
here so for the bottom left
and then we have the bottom right
so for the bottom left we will have x
and y one
so we will just replace this with y one
y 1 everywhere and then this
will remain positive but this will be
negative
again you can play with these and you
can see if it gives you a problem
then you can replace it if you don't
understand it directly
so this is the third one and then for
the fourth one it will be x1 and y1
so we will write here x1 and y1
and the values will be both minus so
both of them will be
inwards there you go
so now it looks much better than just a
rectangle
drawn around it so and yeah one more
thing
i forgot to add is the condition for
drawing so
if we want to draw or not so here i can
write
if draw then we do this
otherwise no need so if i run this
it will draw if i go back here
and where is it here and if i put this
as false
it will give us the values but it is not
going to draw
oh what is that uh
we didn't put that in the draw yeah this
needs to be in the draw
there you go there you go
so now it's not drawing anything at all
and if we go down
and we write here nothing then it will
run because by default it's true
so as you can see now we have our face
detection which is running almost
at 60 plus frame rate which is pretty
amazing given that we are only using a
cpu
and this is an hd video so it is
uh 1280 by 720 if we are running even
lower than this for example 640 by 480
the frame rate will be crazy high so
you can keep that in mind let's try this
one
it's pretty good let's try how many do
we have we have six videos
let's try all of them this is number
four
it's pretty good and you can see here
see that's the thing with our cascades
that it does not detect on the sides so
if you rotate your face it will not
detect at all
but this one does so that is pretty cool
there you go oh this kid is really
enthusiastic
then number six
there you go so
even on the side but if it's gone too
far maybe it will not detect but here
you can see
it's blurry and it's on the side and
even then it is detecting uh
quite a bit that there is a person there
so that is pretty amazing
hey everyone welcome to my channel in
this video we are going to learn
how to detect 468 different landmarks
on faces we will use the model provided
by google
that runs in real time on cpu and on
mobile devices
so here we are in our pycharm project
and we have created a new project called
face mesh project now we have a special
folder here by the name videos
and if you go inside you will see that
we have a couple of videos
in fact more than a couple
you can see here that we have a total of
eight videos
and each of these videos they have a
different size
so they are not actually the same width
and height
you can see this one is smaller so the
frame rate might
vary based on the size
so let's try this one yeah this one is
quite
i think this one is hd or even full hd
probably so yeah so these are some of
the videos that we are going to test on
so what we will do is we will right
click and we will create
a new python file and we are going to
call it face
mesh basics
so what we will do is we will learn the
basics and once we
know the basics we are going to create a
module out of it so that we don't have
to write it again and again
for different projects so the first
thing will be to
install our libraries we will go to file
settings and the project interpreter
and we will add the
open cv python
and we will also add media pipe
which is the library provided by google
that we will be using to
detect all these different 400 plus
points on the faces so
one of them is already done the other
one
is also done great so now we are going
to import cv2
and then we are going to import media
pipe
as mp and then we will
also import time to see the frame rate
so as always the first thing we will do
we will
run our video and we will use
cap is equals to cv2 dot video capture
and we are going to give in our video
path so here it is in videos
videos slash one dot
mp4 uh let's use the second one
because the second one has two faces in
it
so that will be better when we are
testing
okay so then we are going to write
while true
we are going to say uh success
and image is equals to cap dot
read we are going to read our image
and then we will say cv2 dot i am show
we will say that it is an image img
and then cv2 dot weight key as one
so that is pretty much it so
let's run it and see if it works
and there you go so you can see the
video is now running
and we have two faces the first one
i believe has only one yeah and it is
quite big
so it is i think hd uh i mean full hd
so let's try let's
work on number two and later on once we
are done we can try number one
number three four five and so on
okay so the next thing we will do is to
write the frame rate so here we are
going to write
c time is equals to time
dot time and then we are going to write
fps
is equals to 1 divided by
c time minus p time
so p stands for previous c stands for
current time
so then we will write that our previous
time is equals to current time
and up here we are going to define the
previous time
is equals to zero so that should give us
the frame rate
and then all we need to do is we need to
put it
on our image so we will write put text
on the image
and we are going to write fps
and in the curly brackets we are going
to write
integer of fps
and yeah that should be it and then we
have to give in
the location so 2070 and
then we will give in the font cb2 dot
font
let's give it a plain font and what else
then we will give the scale
then the color we will keep it as green
and then we will give in the thickness
so yeah that should be enough
so let's try that out
and there we have it so now we are
getting the frame rate
is quite high at the moment
okay so that is pretty good
we can bring this down
now the next step would be to use our
media pipe library to
actually find the points the different
points on the face
so what do we need first of all we
are going to write here mp
draw is equals to mp.solutions
solutions dot drawing utilities
so this will help us draw on our faces
now we could draw ourselves as well but
the thing is
that when they are using their own
function
they actually make some lines in between
some connections between these points
and
that is quite complicated so rather than
doing it manually we could use their
function
for displaying purposes but if you just
want to see the points
you can just draw circles by yourself as
well i will show you how to do that as
well
okay then we are going to write mp
face mesh is equals to
face mesh is equals to
mp dot solutions
dot face underscore mesh
so we will be using uh this to actually
create our face mesh so we will write
here
face mesh is equals to mp
face mesh dot face mesh
i know it's quite a bit of repetition
but
this is what we need to actually create
our
object and from where we can actually
find our faces so then
inside this if i
press the control button and i click on
this it will take me
to the function itself
to the class face mesh and here it will
tell me
that what is the what are the input
arguments
so here we can see its static image mode
is false then we have the total number
of faces
then minimum detection confidence and
the minimum tracking confidence
so the static image is whether you are
using it only for detection or you are
using detection and tracking
so if it is a static image mode it will
always detect in
each and every single image but if it is
false then it will detect and then it
will track
so detection is always heavier than
tracking
so therefore we will detect first
whatever the confidence is above 0.5
which means that it has found the
probability of 50
for a face then we are going to detect
and then we are going to keep tracking
that face if the tracking confidence is
higher than 50
as well so we can change these
parameters as well
but for now we are not going to do
anything here
uh actually we can change the maximum
number of faces because
uh we want to detect two faces so here
we can write
max number of faces is equals to two
uh the rest we can keep it as it is
so then we are going to go down here and
this
actually accepts this class actually
accepts
only an rgb image so we have to convert
it
so here this image is bgr so we will
convert it so we will write image
rgb is equals to cv2 dot
cvt color and then we will write image
cb
2 dot color underscore bgr
to rgb
so that is the idea and then we can
simply write
results is equals to face mesh
dots process and we are going to send in
our rgb image so that
is the idea and now what you will see is
that the frame rate has dramatically
reduced
there you go so now we are getting right
50s to 60s
which is actually quite high considering
that i'm only using cpu
but if we do it on the first one
uh it will be slower because that is
full hd
video yeah so it's around 40s
and if we are doing it on an hd video
then it is around 60s
so that is pretty amazing
okay so that is good and now we are
getting some results
but now we need to display them so to
display them
we are going to write if results
dot multi-face multi
underscore face underscore landmarks
then if something is detected then we
are going to
go ahead and draw but the thing is that
you can have multiple faces here
so you need to loop through the faces
before we actually draw
so to do that we will write here for
face
landmarks let's say face landmarks
um in results dot
multi multi
underscore face underscore landmarks
we are going to go ahead and loop
through that
and for that we are going to now draw we
will write here mp draw
dot draw landmarks and
then we are going to give in our
parameters
so if we go over here you can see that
you have the image
you have the landmark list you have the
connections so
here first of all we will give in our
image
then we have the landmarks which is
basically
your face lms these are the face
landmarks
and then the connections so we are going
to
write uh mp face
mesh dot face
connections so let's try that out
let's move it a little bit here okay
let's try that out
and there you go so
as you can see now we are getting the
faces
and both the faces are being detected
and if you
go back and you write here one you will
see that only one face is detected
there you go and you can see how
fast and accurate that is which is
pretty amazing to see
okay so what if you want to change
the size of let's say the thickness of
the circles
or the thickness of the lines around it
so what what if you want to do that
well to do that you can write
here some specifications so you can
write here
draw no not mp
draw draw specs
is equals to mp draw
dot drawing specifications
and there you can write that my
thickness is equals to 1
and my circle radius is equals to 2.
let's see because i'm changing right now
i think initially
it is 1 1 or 2 2 something like that so
we are changing it a little bit so that
we can see an effect
so once we do that then we will go to
our mp draw
over here and we are going to write
our specifications here so
we will say that landmark landmark
uh drawing spec i think it is the next
one so we can directly write yeah
so these are the next two parameters so
we can directly write them
so we can write here that it is draw
specs and then again draw specs
so let's run that and there you go
so now you can see it has changed and
um let's say i increase the radius like
dramatically let's put it five
so there you go so now you can see all
these
weird points and let's see let's
increase this as well to five
and there you go so now it is completely
blocked
so anyways you get the idea so you can
put one one here
one one with an hd video is fine you
know it looks good
but if you have a full hd video then one
one
is is way too subtle at least to me
like i can't really see the points here
so if you put maybe two
and you put here two then it is more
visible
yeah something like that
so anyways you can play around with this
all day and you can see which one suits
you the best
so this is basically the the basic idea
of how you can draw now that is all well
and good but
in reality when you are creating a
project you need to use these points
you need to know their positioning to
actually use them
in a project so how can you get the
actual points
now there are a total of 406
points so that's a lot but what we can
do is we can at least
look at them and we can maybe number
them maybe you don't know which one is
which
so we can put the numbering over there
to see
which is the nose which are the starting
of the lips starting off the eye
edge of the eye and so on so
how do you get these values
so what we will do is now here we are
getting into one face
so face lms is the landmarks of
one face now in order to
now in order to get further deep and
find out all the different points we are
going to add another loop
so we will write here for lm
in face landmarks dot
landmark
we are going to get each of these
landmarks and we are going to print it
so we are going to write here print lm
so if i run this now
you will see these are the landmarks so
you get the x position you y position
and z position
so this is the basic idea
so now these landmarks we are going to
first
convert them into pixels so that we can
use them right now they are normalized
from zero to one
so we are going to write here i h iw
and ic i stands for image image height
image
width image channels is equals to image
dot shape so when when we get the shape
now we can multiply it with the
normalized values to get the actual
pixel values
so what we are going to look at is the x
and y
if you want the z as well you can add
that as well
but i'm going to write x and y only so
to get the x and y value all we have to
do is we have to write
l m dot x and then
we have to multiply it with the width
and for the height we will write lm
[Music]
dot y multiplied by eye height
so that is the basic idea so now we have
our values
uh in terms of pixels and we can do
whatever we want
with them so let's first of all print
them out so we will write here
x and y and we can comment this part
so let's run that and if we go back
you can see these are the points that we
are getting
so if we want to get the id for it well
we can put it in a list and we can check
the index of that list
but if you just want to look at it you
can write here enumerate
and here you can write
id and what you can do is you can write
here id
so that will give you the id number and
then it will tell you
the actual value so here you can see
it starts at or does it start
okay it starts here at zero and then all
the way
it goes till 467.
so we have a total of 468 values
and each value has an x and a y
point so a y x and a y
number so here what we will do is
we will put this in a list
so what we can do or
or let's let's keep it till here and
then now what we can do is we can create
this into a module
and in the module we are going to put it
in a list and we will return something
so let's keep the basics still here that
we are getting the numbers and
everything
and yeah that should be good so let's
run it
for two faces and let's run it
with video number two
there you go so if we go down here you
will see
a lot of values being generated
that's good
we could also add uh an enumerate here
and we could write which face number are
we talking about face number one or face
number two
but uh let's let's forget that and
let's go ahead and do the
what you call module
so the idea of the module is that once
you create the module you don't have to
write all of this
initializations and all of this
conversions
again and again so all you need to do is
you need to call
that function or that method within our
class
and that will do the magic for you and
it will return you the values
and you will be happy to work with it
so how do we do that we right click we
go to new
we create a python file we call it face
mesh
mod dual mod
tulle okay so what we will do is we will
go ahead and copy
all of our code and now we are going to
convert this into a module
so for the module the first thing we
have to do is we have to
write what to do if you are running the
module by itself
so we will write here if underscore
underscore
name is equals to
underscore underscore main
then we are going to run our main
function
and we will define our main function
here
main and we will write down our loop
inside it
so we will copy this part actually we
will cut it
and we will paste it here and then we
will go here and we will cut this
and we will paste it here and what else
we will cut this and we will place it
above the while so that gives
us the initial part so
if we were to comment all of this
and if we were to run this it should run
so let's try that
there you go so this is like we are
starting from the scratch
um okay so then
we are going to convert it into a class
so here we are going to write
class is equals to
face mesh detector you can write a
better name
probably but we are going to use face
mesh detector
and then we are going to define our
initial
method uh for initialization and
we are going to given some parameters
now
these parameters will be the ones that
are
uh where is it this one so for the face
mesh
so whatever parameters we have here we
are going to
give in to our object so let me write
down here
so we have static image mode so we will
write here
static mode is equals to
false so this will be by default false
and then max faces is equals to 2
by default then minimum
detection confidence is equal to 0.5
and then minimum track
confidence is equals to 0.5
so we are going to write these and then
we have to tell that
these are the values of this instance
so we will copy this twice
then we will copy this again
we will copy this again
and we will copy this again
so here we will put equals to equals to
equals to an equals to and here we will
write self
self dot this
so we will copy that self.self.self.
so if you are not familiar with this i
would highly recommend that you check
out
uh object oriented programming uh the
basics of
object-oriented programming so
then we are going to uncomment this
and we are going to write self in front
of
each of these and then
we are going to write self here as well
and here
in the max number of faces and all of
this
we need to write our
new variables so here we have
self.static mode
self dot faces
then minimum detection
let's write it in a new line and then
minimum
tracking so that is the idea
so that is good for initializations uh
this if you want to make it
a parameter here as well feel free to do
that
i think it should be fine without it
okay so next we are going to write a
function called
or a method called find
mesh face or faces
i don't know find face mesh let's say
face mesh and then we will write
of course self and then why is it not
okay the indentation is wrong it should
be here
okay so then we are going to write image
and
draw so we will have a option to
uh draw or not draw so it will be a flag
so we can uncomment this
and we can go back up here and
then we will see what is missing so this
indentation is wrong so we need to go
back
okay so then we will just copy this self
dot
and again we will start putting the self
dot
everywhere and
self dot results uh
self.mp draw whatever it's giving an
error just put a self dots
okay so that is good and
wait what happened here
i need to go back okay so that is good
and
now we should be able to see
our results without going into the
returning part
we should be able to see the result but
we didn't
create an object or we didn't call the
find face so it will not do anything
so we need to do that we will write here
detector
detector is equals to
uh face mesh detector
and then here we are going to write here
that
our image is equals to
detector dot
face mesh or is it find
find face mesh here find face mesh and
we will give in our image
and we will keep its
true for the drawing part and here we
are going to return our image
so we will write here return image
so that should be good and let's see if
it works
there we go so now it's working as
an object but the last thing we have to
do
is we have to convert this so that
we are getting our values in return
so that's the main thing so and again
the drawing part again is optional so we
can
directly put here if draw then do this
so if i run this now it should draw
if i go down here and i write here false
false it should not draw
it will work but it will not draw
anything
so that's good okay so
what is next yeah so now we need to
uncomment this
and for every face we are going to
go through every landmark and through
every landmark
we are going to convert it into x and y
and then we need to
store it so where do we store it we
store it
in let's say a variable called
face so this will be a list
so we will store it in list face dot
append
and we are going to append the
x and y so this will be the x and y
value
now that is good for one face but we
have
multiple faces so what do we do we
create
another list we call it faces
plural and this time around
we append after the loop
we append faces dot append
face so basically
when we are uh looking for the landmarks
we append the landmarks in the faces and
then once we have that
face with all the landmarks then we
append the faces
so that we get the final result so that
is the basic idea
actually let's put it outside so it
doesn't give random error
that it has been used before declaration
so yeah so in any case we are going to
return faces
so even if it's empty it doesn't matter
we are going to return it
so that's the idea and then in the image
here i can write here faces
and that should return the faces
what we can do we can print here so we
can write here
if the
how can we write this the length of
faces
but if we write the length of faces it
will be
yeah it will be something okay yeah that
should work if the length of faces is
not equals to zero
then we are going to print the length of
faces let's say
so let's see how many faces do we get
okay we are printing a lot of things
that's why we are not
having a clearer picture so
yeah let's run it again
there you go so now it is showing one
face
and why is it showing one face because
we put we put maximum two phases why is
it showing one
that is weird max faces is
two did we say something here
are we running the module yeah we are
running the module still saying one
okay let's see why does it say one
so it should be four
oh this should be inside the loop my bad
so now it should work there you go
so now you have two faces being detected
and if we go to video number one
where is that with your number one then
it will be one face so you can see here
it's only one face so that is the idea
and then
what we can do is to check whether we
are on the
uh correct path or not we can write here
faces at zero let's see what does it
print
so oh actually it's printing the length
no no we
yeah actually it's good to see that it
has 468 points
so that means we are getting all the
points that is good but now
let's print all the points it will be a
long list
there you go so now you can see these
are all the different points
that we have so this
is quite good okay so one more thing
we can do now if you're not familiar
with which point
is which number then what you can do is
you can print
the id number over here so you can write
that cv2 actually we wrote it somewhere
yeah why write it again
if we have it already we can write here
that cv2.put
text and we are going to put the text
of our id so let's just
write here string id
and where do we need to put it we need
to put it at
x and y
so this is the x and y position uh 3
is way too big so we are going to put it
as 1
1. let's see how that works out
so this is going to print out the id
number of
each of the points oh boy
okay so it's like a matrix
okay so that is bad um maybe we need to
look at a video that
is uh more focused on the face
doesn't have a lot of other stuff let's
see
maybe this one maybe this one will be
better
let's try that this number
six
there you go so now it's much better so
still not that good we
first of all let's let's change the
maximum
to uh max faces is equals to one
so we only look at one face and
then let's put this
as 0.5
okay it's going to the kid i was hoping
it will attach
to the elderly person but no it did not
happen
okay let's keep the maximum faces as 2
and let's make this even smaller 0.3
let's try that no that's not readable
0.5 is let's try that again
okay so i can see 1 is here 4 5
then it goes to 195. 151
9 8 so yeah it's a little bit harder to
read still
1.7
yeah now it's a little bit better here
at the edges you can see very clearly
what are the points numbers so 21 54 103
is 67
and so on but in the middle area
especially with the nose i think one i
can see one here
so one is the nose uh the center of the
nose
let's let's try another video hopefully
we will get something better
so number by the way you can read all of
this in the paper
so if you go to media pipe website they
have a paper listed there and
if you go in the paper you will find
these
you'll find more information on these
points
so yeah no it's hard to
see with this uh maybe if you have just
an image and you apply that
apply this method on the image and then
you scale it up
to see the numbers maybe that will work
so anyways this is the basic idea of how
you can
detect 468 points
on a face and that running on a cpu all
of this
running only on a cpu so that is
a pretty amazing task and the results
are pretty good
you can see let's try out different
videos so
we have video number one you can see it
is pretty good
video number two actually let's let's uh
remove this part
let's remove the id and uh
let's keep its normal yeah
so let's try it again
wait what happened there uh oh yeah the
draw is false so we need to remove that
there you go that is pretty good you can
see it is very smooth
it's very smooth yeah
then let's try number three
there you go even when the faces
are a bit far it is detecting quite well
number four that is good
okay when it goes to the side it
disappears and that is understandable
then let's try number five
this seems like a like a zoom meeting
yeah could be used in that
with the frame rate we are getting it
could be used
in a zoom meeting okay let's try number
six
there you go uh it's flickering a little
bit here
maybe because they're merging the faces
at some point
we are probably because of that
then let's try number seven how many do
we have
eight yes okay
that's good okay when she goes down
then uh of course it will not detect but
as soon as she gets back up uh
the face is detected there you go
the person is laughing and you can see
that that is pretty good okay so this is
it uh for today's video i hope you have
learned something new
if you like the video give it a thumbs
up and don't forget to subscribe
and share it with your friends and i
will see you
in the next one
hey everyone welcome to my channel in
this video we are going to learn
how to use gesture control to change the
volume of a computer
we will first look into hand tracking
and then we will use the hand
landmarks to find the gesture of our
hand to change the volume
this project is module based which means
we will be using
a previously created hand module which
makes the hand tracking
very easy so here we are in our pyjama
project
this is the same one that we used in the
previous video
so in the previous video we learned
about
hand tracking minimum code the bare
minimum code that is required to run
hand tracking and then we created a
module out of this
so that we don't have to write it again
and again we can simply import this
module
and run it as it is now if you haven't
checked this video
i highly recommend that you go and check
that video out first and then you can
come back here and we will continue with
the
uh hand tracking project so the project
that we are working on
is the let's call it
volume control
or let's call it volume hand control
so we are going to control the volume
of our computer with our hand so that is
something
very interesting now the first thing is
that we will go to file
and we will go to settings we will make
sure that
our uh libraries or packages are
installed so we will write here
opencv python so this is the first one
that we need we will hit
install and then i've already done it
that's why i'm not doing it
then we are going to write media
pipe and we will click on that and we
will hit install
so these are the two main libraries that
we need for now
and later on we can check what we need
uh afterwards
the first thing you have to do is you
have to import your packages so we will
write here
import cv2 then we will import time
and then we have to import numpy
numpy as np so
these are the basic packages that we
will be using
later on we will add some more as well
so the first thing we want to do is we
want to check if the webcam is working
and everything
is running fine so we will write here
that
cap is equals to video capture cv2
cv2.videocapture
and we will write the id number so i'm
using
id1 most probably you will need id 0.
then we will write while true
we are going to check the success
of the capture and then we will write
image
and then we will write cap
dot read so this is the main idea and
then we will write cv2 dot im
show we will write the image and then
img
and then we will write cv2 dot white
key as one so that will give it a one
millisecond delay so
this is looking good let's run it and
see what happens
there you go so this is my hand that we
will be tracking
and we will change the volume from and
this is our webcam
so what can we do okay one more thing we
can do here
is we can write here let's say this is
the part
where we have our
parameters so we can write here that
our cam width let's write width of our
camera
and the height of our camera is equals
to
640 by 480 so we are basically defining
it here
and then we can use it here we can say
cap dot set
prop id number three is width
so we will write with cam and
then prop id
at number four is height cam
so we can write height gap so that
should be good
and let's try it with the different
value 1280 by 720
so this will make it a little bit bigger
yeah there you go so
but we are going to use 640 by 480
instead
okay so that is good what else can we do
we can add the frame rate
so here we are going to write
that our current time is equals to
time dot time and then we have the
fps is equals to 1 divided by
our current time minus the previous time
and then previous time previous time
is equals to current time
so we can define the previous time as 0
over here and what else
so now we can put this fps
on our image so we can write here cv2
dot
put text and we will write image and
then we will write
f p s
and we will write the value of the fps
let's say
integer
fps because it's decimal we don't want
decimal places
and then we can write the the location
70 and then we write the font
so we can put any font that we want
and then we will write the scale
and the color so let's write two five
five zero
two five five and then we will write the
thickness
so that should be good so let's run this
and see if it works
oh it does work but looks really bad
okay so first of all the color is bad so
let's change it to blue so we can remove
this
and then let's try the blue color first
yeah the blue color is much better then
we can
make it smaller it's really big so scale
let's put it as one
yeah that seems good thickness
thickness is fine i think it's fine we
can reduce a little bit but
and then we can push it up a little bit
let's say 50.
yeah now it really looks good and in the
correct place
okay so now that we are all set now we
will do the magic part
the magic part here is that we already
have our
hand tracking module so we don't have to
write a lot of code we will just
use its functionality and we will be
able to
get our hand very quickly the landmarks
of our hand
very quickly so we will write here
imports
hand hand tracking module now
if you don't see hand tracking module
that is because you need to put it in
the same folder
as your project so if it's in the it's
not in the same folder
or if it's not even here then you will
not be able to use it
so you need to make sure it is in the
same folder and we can import it
as something else hdm let's say hand
tracking module
because we don't want to write that
complete name it's quite big
okay so then we will create an object
so this is a class inside here we have a
class
where is it here hand detector
so we will uh create an object from it
we will call it
detector detector
is equals to uh what was the name htm
dot hand detector and then
we have our default parameters already
here so we don't need to write anything
for now
so we will keep it like that and then
what else can we do then after doing
this we need to
find the location or we need to find the
hand
so we will write here that detector
detector dot find hands
so this is the method that we created so
this is this method find hands
and all we need to do is we need to send
in the image
so this will give us the hands
so we want to draw it so we will not
put it as false we will keep the draw as
true
and it gives us the image back so we
will
accept that image back again
so that is pretty much it so we can
we can separate this code not too much
we can separate this code so that it is
easier to read so
now we can run it and see if it works
and there you go so now we are getting
good detection
and it seems quite good
so what happens sometimes you can see it
detects a little bit
on the side and then it detects small
hand as well
so what we want to do is we want to
change the detection confidence here
so at default it is 0.5
so the detection confidence is 0.5 we
wanted to be really sure that it is a
hand
and then only detect the hand this way
when you are changing the volume it will
be a little bit smoother
because it will not flicker too much so
we can write here
detection confidence is let's say 0.7
so you can play around with this value
if you want but i will keep it
at 0.7 yeah
seems fine to me
and then we are going to go to the next
part which is the best part
of getting the position
so now all we have to do to get this
position
is to write that our landmark list
is equals to detector dot
find position and then we just send in
our image
that's it uh and we will also
write draw is equals to false we don't
want to draw it because we are already
drawing it
so we will keep that as false and
now let's run it
and there you go we are getting it but i
forgot to print
so print lm list
so let's run that
and there you go so at the bottom you
can see that we are getting that list
so here we are getting that list
and we have a total of 20 values here
uh 21 values because we are counting 0
as well so we have a total of 21
values now if we want to get
the value of a particular point then we
can
write that point itself so here for
example we need point number
two so this is the landmark number two
so if we run that again
okay so this is a good point we are
getting an
error because the index is out of range
so before we actually print or before we
actually
do anything related to the points we
have to make sure that there are some
points
so we will write here if lm
list the length of it
is not equals to zero
not equals to zero then we are going to
do this otherwise it will skip it
so let's try that and there you go so
now i'm only
getting landmark number two so this is
good
but how do we know which landmark do we
need
so here is the media pipe website and
they have given
us the landmark model information so
these are all the
values that we get all the landmarks
that we get
so here we will need the value number
four
which is for our thumb and we will need
the value number eight
which will be for our index so we need
the tip of both the thumb and the index
so we will go back here and here i can
write
i need the value number four and i need
the landmark list i need the value
number
eight so this way we will get only these
two values
there you go so now i have these values
and you can see they are changing
but to make sure that we are using the
correct ones
we are going to create a circle around
them
so we will write here cv2
dot circle and in the circle
we are going to say that we want to put
it on our image
and then we have to give in the center
value now here what we can do is we can
create some variables so that we don't
have to write
all of this again and again so we can
write here
x1 and y1 is equals to
lm list at number four
and we need the first element of it
so this is the id number zero then this
is
number one element which is the x and
this is the second element
which is the y so we need the first
element as x
and then we need the second element as y
and then we can copy this and we can do
it for the
index as well so we will write
here this is 8 and this one is
8 as well so now i can simply write
x1 and x2 x1 and white
one and then we are going to write
the radius let's say 15 and then we will
give in the color let's say 255
0 and then 255 and then we will write
cb2 dot filled
okay so we can copy this for the other
one and we can paste it here
and we can write x2 and y2
so this will create
two circles at that point so if we are
getting the correct points then it
should draw on the
thumb and the index and there you go so
now you can see that it is drawing on
the thumb
and the index
so this is good now the next thing we
can do
is we can create a line between them
so we can write here cv2.line and within
the line we'll give in our image
and then we will given x1 and y1
and then we will give in x2 and
x2 and y2 and then
we will give in what else do we have
we have the color so two five five zero
two five five
and then we have the thickness
so let's try that out
there you go so now we are getting
the line as well in between
okay so next thing what we have to do
is we have to get the center of this
line
so we can do that simply by writing here
cx
and cy is equals to
x1 plus x2
divided by 2 and then y
1 plus y 2
divided by 2. so we can simply write it
like this
and this will give us the c x and c y
and we can
put a circle for that as well
so let's write here cx and let's write
here
cy so let's try that out
and there you go so now we are getting a
nice circle
in between so this is good
now next thing we can do is to
find the length so this is the most
important thing we need to know
what is the length between these two
points or what is the length of this
line
when we know the length of this line
then we can change the volume based on
that
so what we can do is we can write our
own
function and we can do a little bit of
maths to square it and then square root
but instead we are going to import
math and within math we have the
hypotenuse function
so we will use that so we will write
here that our
length is equals to
math dot hypotenuse
and then inside that we are going to
write
x2 minus x1
and then y2 minus
y1 so that will give us
our length so we can print it out
so let's try that i think we are
printing something
else as well so we need to remove that
first
okay let's try it
okay so here
you can see that when i
increase the distance the value
increases when i decrease it
the value decreases so the maximum you
can say is around 300 something
so we can say let's say it's 300
and the minimum let's say is 50. okay
so this is the maximum and minimum that
we have
so one thing we can do is we can write
here that if
our length is less than 50
then we want to change the color of our
center circle
so let's make it green
so this will give it like a button
effect so when you're pressing it
it changes so here
let's let it load okay so here when we
come closer there you go so now
it actually feels like a button and
it is very soothing i don't know why but
it's pretty cool
and it's quite fast so it is good
so this is good and now what we can do
is
we can uh change the volume
based on this length so how can we do
that
well we have a couple of libraries that
can help us with this
the one that i found was pico
i don't know why it says call
but it is developed by entry miras
so thanks to him for developing this
awesome library which allows us to
change the volume of our computer so it
is
under the mit license and if you go down
you have to just write pip install pico
and
then you can use this code as the
template so i will copy this
because i'm lazy and i will paste it
here
okay so now what we have to do is we
have to simply
go to file settings
and we will add pico by call
you can do pip install as well it's the
same thing so we can click on pico and
we can click on install
so that is installed and we are good to
go if we go back you will see all the
errors are gone
so we will copy the imports
and we will we will cut them and we will
paste it at the top
and the rest of it we are going to see
what do we need and what we don't
so what we can see here here is that we
have the volume
get mute so this seems like
the initializations so we are not going
to change anything there
then here we have volume dot get mute uh
we don't want that
then we have get master volume level
um do we need i don't think we need that
we might need the volume range and then
we have
volume dot master volume so we can set
the volume
so before we set it let's see what is
the range
so i can print this
and there you go so our range is from
-65
to 0. so this is our range
so we are going to use these two
parameters so
0 will be maximum and 65 will be minimum
we will ignore this value
so if i set the volume
as -20 let's run it
and see what happens
so right now it is at 26 the volume goes
to 26.
if i set it as let's say minus 5
let's see what happens to the volume it
goes to 72.
and if i put it as zero
then you can see it goes to 100 so
this is basically the idea so what we
can do is we can get the minimum and
maximum range
so we can write here
that our volume range is equals to
volume
get volume range and then we will say
that
um or we will keep it like this let's
keep it like this we can
take the values later on or i think it's
better to write
so we'll write here minimum volume is
equals to
uh volume range
at one visit
yeah at zero and then maximum volume
is at one
so this is our range okay so now we can
use minimum volume and maximum volume
instead of using this
okay so what is the next thing that we
need to do now the next thing
is we need to convert our volume ranges
so as you saw that our
minimum and maximum was 350.
so we were getting let's write it after
the length
so here we know that our
our hand range
was from 300 was the maximum
and the minimum was 50. so it was from
50 to
300. now we need to convert it
to our volume range so our volume range
is from uh minus 65
to zero so we need to convert
this range into this range
so in order to do that we have a very
simple function in numpy
so we have did we include yes we
included numpy
so in numpy we can write here
volume is equals to numpy
dot interpret
and inside that we are going to give in
the value that we want to convert
so we want to convert the length and now
we have to give in the range
so our range was 50 to 300
and then now we have to give in the
range to which we want to convert
so our range here is the minimum
minimum volume and this will be the
maximum volume
so let's print this out
so let's print the volume
so let's remove that
and let's see if this works
so right now it's minus 25 if i go down
it goes to minus 65 so here
our volume is zero and if i go
up you can see it should go till zero
yeah
there you go this is the maximum so this
is good
uh if you are a little bit confused you
can write the length here as well
so the length and the volume you can see
side by side we can make it
let's make it integer that doesn't give
weird values
so yeah here you can see
when we have the minimum volume
then it gives us minus 65 and then when
the length is maximum it gives us zero
so this is exactly what we wanted
so now that we have converted this we
can simply
send it to our master volume so we have
the function here
we can actually remove it from here
and we can go down and after the volume
we can
paste it here so set master volume level
we are going to set it as our volume
so let's try this
so i will open up my volume and
let's try this there you go
so if i go to zero it goes to zero as
well if i increase the length you can
see
and now it goes to the maximum i think
300 is
a little too far well it's fine you can
see i can change the volume from here
you can make it a little more smoother
as well by changing the range of these
two over here and even this you can play
around with
because i can see it's not very
proportional so you can play around with
those values
to make some changes now the last thing
we can do is
we can show the volume bar
on the side so that it looks a little
bit nice
to see what is the volume at any given
point
so what we can do here is that we can
create a rectangle so we will go down
and we will write here cv2 dot rectangle
and we will put it on our image we will
give it
the initial position and then we will
give it the ending position so
we will give that and then we will give
in the color so let's make it green
and then we will write cb2 dot filled
so this is the idea so the width of our
bar is basically 85
minus 50 which is 35 so if we run this
there you go so this is our bar and
what we have to do is we have to remove
the fill
we don't want to fill we want let's say
three
so let's run that yeah so there is our
bar
and then the next part will be filled
so the next part here we will copy this
and
now we will give in the volume
so we will say that our width is the
same
but the height will be different so we
will write here
integer our height so volume
of this and do we need to change
anything else
uh not really so here we need to change
cb2 dot
filled so if we run this
volume is not defined oh yeah volume is
not defined here
so we can write here volume is equals to
zero
okay there you go so now you can see
that
it's going out of the uh what he called
image
so if i try to change let's try to
change
does it change no because it
is too big for us so what we need to do
is we need to convert
our range again so in this
instance our range is from
let's say 400 so 400
let me show you here so 400 is at this
point so this is the height 400
so when our volume is 0 it should be 400
and at this point we have what do we
have
we have 150 when the volume is maximum
it should be
150 so our new range so we can
write here that this is volume for the
bar
so we will write here it's again 50 from
300
till 300 but the minimum now is
400 and the maximum is
150 so instead of volume we will send in
volume bar so let's run that
okay now volume bar is not defined so we
need to write here volume bar
and let's do volume as well volume
is equals to zero okay
let's run it
it's still the same why where did i make
a mistake
volume bar is from
so where is the issue let's
run it again and see
if i put my hand in ah okay
so the first value is wrong
so we need to go up here and volume bar
should be 400 so it is at the first
point it should be zero
so our zero is at 400 so there you go so
now if i bring in my hand
and now if i change you can see it
changes the value
there you go so the last thing we can do
is to add a percentage at the bottom so
we can copy this
and we can paste it here
and in the text we are going to give in
our percentage
but again we don't have any percentage
so
we can create another conversion here
we can write here volume percentage
is equals to 50 to 300 and now it will
be from 0 to 100
so we need the percentage of that and
then we can write here that
our volume this is our
volume should we write volume or let's
just keep it like this
and then we can write here volume
percentage and then we can write
percentage in front of that but the
location let's put it 440
let's keep it at 40 and then let's put
this as 450
and let's keep the rest same or let's
change the color
let's make it green so it matches that
so let's try that out
okay volume percent i always forget this
volume percentage is not defined you
need to define it as zero
or should it be zero uh yeah it should
be zero
okay so zero percent
64 it's hard to see this color
let's change the color completely so
let's keep it as
blue so i will copy the blue color
where is it from the fps
and we will put it for all of these
okay let's try it again
yeah now it's much much clearer so here
we can see
so 100 is a little bit hard to reach so
instead of 300
i can make its 250 for example 275
but now you can see the percentage is
changing let me
show the volume bar and you can see here
that the percentage
is changing
hey everyone welcome to my channel in
this video we are going to learn
how to count fingers we will first look
into hand tracking
and then we will use the hand landmarks
to count
the fingers and all of this will be
happening in real time
and it requires close to no
installations and configurations
so here we are in our python project and
you can see that this is the same
project
that we used in our previous two videos
in the first video we looked at the bare
minimum code that is required to do the
hand tracking parts
and once that was done we created that
into a module
so that we do not have to write the code
again and again
and it will be easy for us to create new
projects
so this will be one of those examples
where we create a project out of this
module
another example that we did earlier was
the volume hand control
and you can see here that this was the
code that we did earlier
so all of this is available on my
website
and now what we will do also there is
another folder here
you can see that it says finger images
so basically what this
is that we have the images
of different fingers so when it is one
when it is two
three four five and one it is zero
so we can have very specific ones as
well
where you have the index and the pinky
finger up
so then you can have only the thumb up
and you can have all sorts of different
scenarios
but for simplicity we are just going to
use these six scenarios
but if you want to add more later on you
can do that
and it will pretty much use the same
code and you can keep adding on to it
okay so once we are in our project we
will go to file
settings and we will make sure that
everything is installed
now because this is the same project i
know that the packages are already
installed
but if somebody is doing this for the
first time then i will show you what you
have to do
so here you will write opencv dash
python and you will install this
and then you will go to media pipe
media pipe and then you will install
this
so both of these are installed so we
don't have to worry about that and then
we will go
to our project we will create a new file
and this time around we are going to
call it
finger something finger counting
projects let's say so the first thing we
will do
is to import our cv2 the opencv library
then we will import
time and do we need anything else we
will also
import os so i will tell you why we need
os
later on now the first thing as always
we will turn on our webcam
so here we will write cap is equals to
cv2 dot video capture and we are going
to give in device number one
most probably for you it will be device
number zero
and then you have the option of giving
the size
so you can write for example cap dot set
and here we are going to write that this
is number three
number three is for the width so i can
write the width
of the cam and then i can write cap dot
sets and the heights of the cam
so we need to define the width and
height so the width
of the cam and the height of the camera
is equals to 640 by 480.
so we can write it like this and what
else
so then we have to write our while loop
so while
true then we are going to write here
success
and image is equals to cb2
dot
cap dot read so it will read our frame
then we write cb2 dot
i am show and inside that we write
image and then img
and at the end of the day we have to
give it a delay so cb2 dot
weight key as one so this will give it
a one millisecond delay so that we can
see our images
okay so what else okay the spellings
here are wrong success
okay so let's try this out and see if we
are on the right track
so this is my webcam and you can see my
hand
and that seems good okay so next
we are going to do something new here
and that will be to import our images
so we have all these images so what we
need to do is we need to get them
one by one and then we want to store
them
so that later on whenever we have
the certain amount of fingers shown then
we can display that image
so we need to store them first so how do
you store it
you will use os so what we can do is
we can write here that let's say our
list my list is equals to
os dot list directory so we want to list
the directory
we want to list all the files that are
present in finger images
so we will say that our folder path
is equals to finger
finger images so i will copy
this and i will paste it here so now if
we print this out
you will see that we get a complete list
there you go so we get all the names
so one thing to note here is that i have
put them in order
and the last one is zero so
when there are no fingers then it will
be zero here
now you might say why didn't you put it
here in the beginning and there is a
reason why and i will show you later on
why this is the reason uh what is the
reason
so then we are going to
create a list of images
so we can say list of images or we can
say
let's say overlay because we want to
overlay this image
on our main image so we will say overlay
list is equals to empty
and now we can loop through our list so
we can say that
for image path
in our list
we want to create we want to import our
image
so we will write here image is equals to
cv2 dot im read
and then we have to given the path of
the image
so this is the path of the image so it
is in finger images and it is
one dot jpg so one dot jpg is basically
this
i am path and then our folder path is
basically
finger images so we can write here
f and then we can write here folder
path okay f needs to be small
folder path and then we can write
slash and then we can write our image
path
so we can write here
image path impact
okay so now if you're confused let me
show you what this will look like
so you can go here and we can print this
and we can skip the import or we can
import
doesn't really matter so there you go
so for each of the images you get this
finger images
at one dot gpg then finger images 2.jpg
and so on so this way we get all the
paths
and we can simply import now we have
imported it
let's keep it there we have imported it
but we didn't save it so we need to save
it in our list
so we will say overlay list dot append
and we want to impend our image
so that will give us our emit list now
to confirm
that everything is working fine we can
write here length of
our overlay list and we can write here
print so if that list is six
then we should be good to go
and there you go so the value is six so
this means we have imported
all these images and we are good to go
so how exactly do we overlay an image
now the thing is that image itself is a
matrix
so what we can do is we can define that
our new image
we want to put in our old image based on
this location so what we can say is that
our
image is equals to so if i wanted the
elements the first element of this list
i would say overlay list one or overlay
list zero
right so the same way if i want to
target a specific region
of my image then i can write that target
space in this bracket so this is also
called
slicing so what we will do is we will
give
in the height first the range of the
height and then we will give the range
of the width
so we will say that i want to put my
image
this overlay image whatever it is let's
say we are using
overlay uh list
at number zero so we are using the first
image
so i want to put that at zero
wait what happens uh i think
insert is pressed or yeah okay
0 and then 200
this is the limit of my height and then
0
to 200 this is the limit of my width
so now now the reason i'm putting 200 is
because
these images are 200 so the size of this
image is basically 200 by 200
so we can automate that i will show you
how to do that too
so let's try this and see if it works so
i will run this
and there you go so now you can see the
image number one
is displayed at 200 by 200
so this is 0 0 and this is 200 200
so our image is now displayed properly
if i wanted to shift this
i can write for example 100 here and
then 100 here
so we are getting an error that we have
hundred and two hundred
uh okay so the problem is that
the image is of size 200 by 200
and they are saying that you cannot
convert it to 100 by 100
so here hours if i'm increasing 100 here
i need to increase 100 here as well
so that it maintains that 200 size
so if we run this now
then you can see that the image has
shifted down
so this is how you can place your image
within
our original image so here we are going
to write 0 and 200
and 0 and 200 but
now we want to automate this so let's
say you don't have
a 200 by 200 image you have something
else
your the size of the image is something
else and even the size of each image
could be different
so what can we do then what we can do is
we can write here
that for example we are using overlay
list 0
okay so we will write here overlay list
0
dot shape so this will give us that
shape
and we can store it in height
width and channel because we have
these three things and then we can
replace this with height and we can
replace this with
width so if we run this now
then it will give us the same effect
because we don't have to worry about
uh the size of the image it will put it
on the corner
so this is good now we understand how to
overlay
our finger image on the original image
now what we can do is we can display the
frame rate
so here we can write current time
is equals to time dot time
and then we have to write fbs
is equals to 1 divided by current time
minus the previous time
and the previous time we have to declare
up
here in we will put it
as 0 and then we will say that
our previous time is equals to
the current time so this will update
every loop
and then we can simply write cv2
dot put text we will write in our image
and then we will write the
then we will write the fps
as an integer and we will write here
fbs and what else
then we will write the uh what do you
call
the location so we can put 470
and then we will write cv2 dot
font any of these and then
we will have the scale
and then the color
and then the thickness
so let's try this out and see if we get
a good image whoa that is
really big so
let's change this to font
plane
there you go so now it is quite good
and we can see that it is working
so that is good so the next thing would
be to
actually go into our hand tracking part
so here we are going to go up and we
will import
we will import our module
which is the hand tracking module and we
will import it as
h m so this is what we will do
or let's say htm hand tracking module
and then we will create
uh not here we will go down and here we
are going to create
a detector so we will write here the
detector
is equals to hdm dot
hand detector and we will not give it
any values or should we we can give it
the detection confidence so we can keep
it a little bit higher
so 0.75 let's say later on if we get
some errors we can change that too
so that is good so here we are going to
write that we want our detector to
find the hands and we will send in our
image
and we will just ask it ask it to return
our image
so if we go to the hand tracking module
you will remember that this is our class
hand detector class inside that we have
a method called
find hands and it just needs an image
and it will
output the image with the drawing so we
can write here image we will return
image back and if we print this
it should uh draw our hand
so there you go so we have our hand and
it is drawing nicely
so that should be good and then what we
can do is we can
create a list of the landmarks that we
detect
so we will say that detector dot
find position and we want it to find the
position within our image
and we want to draw
as false because we are already drawing
so we don't want to draw again
so we will write here that drawing is
false and
then we can print our lm list
to see if we are getting something
so right now it's empty and when i bring
in my hand
you can see that the list fills up
so that is good and now what we can do
is we can write here
that if the length
of our lm list is
not equals to zero then we are going to
do something
so that something could be anything so
what we are trying to do is
that we are trying to get the tip of our
fingers and based on that tip we can
decide
whether our fingers are open or closed
so here is the website of
media pipe and we can see that
these are our landmarks so what we have
to do is we have to first of all
get all these points so we need point
number four
point number eights 12 16 and 20.
so we need to use these and then we need
to check
whether these are below let's say
number six or number seven i think it's
better to take number
six you can even use number five but i
think number 5 will be too much
so you can say that if number 8 is below
number 6 then it is what he called
closed
then the finger is closed and if it is
above six then the finger is open
so what we can do is we can pick one of
these
and we can try it out and then we can
apply it to the rest of them
so let's say we pick our index finger so
this is
eight and six so what we will do is
we will write here that if
the lm list at number 8
we will get the value of the y
not the x so y is the third element so
it will be 0
1 and 2 so we will write here 2. so
if the point number 8
is less than the point number
point number six then it means it is
open
so in that case we will write here print
index finger
open
so because we are using the
open cv orientation so up means
lower values so our image is starting
from the top
so the maximum value at the maximum
height is zero
so to check for example here our value
is 50
and here our value is 100 then it means
our
finger is open if it's the opposite if
it's 100 here
and then 50 here then it is it means it
is closed
so here we are going to try out and see
if it says finger open
so here right now it's saying finger
open if i close it
you will see that it stops saying
actually let me remove the print
it's quite annoying so
let's run it again
so right now it will say index finger
open
if i stop if i close then it will stop
and if i open it again it will say index
finger open
so this is how you can tell if the
finger is open or not
so now we need the tip points for each
one of these
so for each finger we need a point now
we could write
a lot of if statements and if you are
using a lot of different types
for example if you have the pinky finger
and the index one
up as well and then you consider that a
different gesture than
your two fingers of any kind for example
the index finger and the middle finger
up
so if you want to differentiate between
these then you have to create
lots of different images lots of
different scenarios but here we are only
going to use six scenarios
so we can simply use a for loop so what
we will do is
we will create a list here and we will
call it
tip ids and this tip ids will be
basically number four which is for the
thumb
number eight for the index number 12 for
the middle finger
then 16 for the ring finger and then 20
for the pinky finger so these are the
tips
and then what we can do is we can put a
for loop here
and then we can change this value so
here we can say for
let's say id in range
what is the range from 0 to
5 we are going to
repeat this and here we are going to
put in the value so the idea is that we
have our id
number four so we can write here tip ids
at number id
okay and the other value so here you can
see it is eight
and here it is six so it is minus two
so whatever value we have here minus
2 so this minus 2.
so this should basically
loop and it should tell us for each one
of these
but once it tells us that if the finger
is open or not
we need to save that so here we can
write
fingers fingers is equals to
empty and here we can write fingers dot
append we can append either one
or we can append
zero so
if the finger is open
then we will append one if the finger is
closed
then we will append zero so here we will
write
prince fingers
so let's see how that works out
so if we have our hand in
you can see all the fingers are open
if i close all of them close except for
the thumb
so we will discuss the thumb but let's
try the other ones out
so here we have one the index finger
then the middle finger
then the ring finger
and then the pinky finger
so you can see it is really good i can
do one
two three and four there you go so that
is amazing
so what i was saying earlier is that for
example if you have this pose
it will show you that the
index is open and the pinky is open
but for images we are still going to use
this image
that it will show us that there are two
fingers open
because we are not using all the
scenarios
now one thing you have noted is that the
in the thumb is an issue
and the reason is that the tip of the
thumb
is not acting the same way so we are
using
the tip at this point so this is the
point where we are using the tip
and we are saying that when it is below
this point
because -2 will be here at this point
so this basically is never going below
that
if i really push my finger maybe
not even then so that is not a good way
to check it
so how can we check it can we say that
if this
is below instead we can write -1
even in that case it is very hard to
bring it below that
maybe now it will say zero but it will
be very hard
so how can you tell if the thumb is
closed or not
so for the thumb what we actually do is
naturally when we are closing we put it
on the side
we don't bring it down we put it on the
side
so we can check whether this point here
at the top
is on the left of the second point
or on the right so right now it's on the
right
now it's on the left so when it comes
to the left side we will say it is
closed and when it's on the right side
we will say it's open
so this is the idea so let's see how we
can do that
so what we will do is we will keep this
for loop for the four fingers
so we will just make it one to five and
then
over here we are going to create another
loop uh not another loop just an if
statement
and we will say that the id number one
which is the x axis is less than
this point id number one and then we
will
check minus one not the uh
two values below only one value below
only one
landmark below so if you are not
clear about this i'm talking about this
point number three
so if this point is on this side
then we will consider it closed if this
point is
on this side of the point so
here it is on the left then we will
consider it
open so keep in mind for the left and
for the right hand
it will be different so if you are doing
it for the right hand
uh it will be the same what i am doing
if you are doing it for the left hand
then you can uh do it the other way
around
now you might say that if i am using it
with the left hand with this code it
will not work yes it will not work
but there is a possibility of checking
whether it's a left hand or a right hand
and then based on that
you can change your parameters you can
change the if statement
based on that so it is not something
very complicated it's very simple
but right now we will just focus on the
right hand
so here what we will do is uh okay we
have already written the code
so we don't need to do anything else so
we can write here thumb
thumb and we can write here
uh four fingers
so that is the idea so let's try this
out if it works or not
okay we have another
must be integers or slices
okay uh oh there's no id my bad
so there's no id we have to get our id
by itself so this will be number zero
so let's run that again
okay then we have another issue
tip ids zero one
okay i think there's an issue with the
brackets
so there should be a bracket here
so tip ids add
zero yeah
and then the first part of it so the
bracket should be here
and over here uh it will be
tip ids minus one and there you go
so it should be like that
okay so now you can see it is zero
when it should be one so it is basically
opposite so we need to make it
greater than
so now you can see all of them are one
if i put my thumb
if i close it you can see it says zero
so that's how easy it is so now if i put
all of them closed you can see it says
zero and if i open
i can open one by one two three
four and five and i can get all the
detections so that is good now the next
thing we have to do
we have to change our image so to change
the image first of all we need to know
how many fingers did we actually get
so to do that we can
actually let's go up here let's comment
this and instead
we are going to write here that our
total fingers
total
total fingers is equals to
fingers dot count so
this is a method in our list
so we have a list in which we can
use the count method to count the number
of
values present of what of
the number one so basically we are
saying
find how many uh ones do you have
i think the indentation of this is wrong
so we need to fix that okay
so then we can print the
total fingers let's try that
oh it has no attribute counts
because c is supposed to be small
okay so let's try that
here we have 5 0
1 2 3 4
5 4 3
2 1 0. there you go
so now it's looking good and all we have
to do now
is to change our image so how can we
change the image so here we have the
code for changing
so we will bring it in the loop
or what is it in the if statement
so we will bring it in the if statement
and then
we have to change the value over here
so we have to put a value based on the
total fingers
so already we have laid down if it is
finger number one
it should be element number zero so we
can take
this total fingers
wait what happened total fingers
minus one so if it is one
it will become zero so it will take this
image
if it is two it will become one
and it will take this image so this is
how it will work
so let's see if it changes we are taking
the shape of zero we should take the
shape of the same image
even though all of them are same doesn't
matter at this point but
overall it could be different okay so we
have 5 now
and then we have zero one
two three four five
so that's how easy it is one two three
four five
and it looks like an animation if i do
it fast
and it's running real time so it looks
really good now you might say we didn't
add zero
we didn't we actually never said go till
six
so this value of total fingers can be
let's say
at five maximum right and then five
minus one is four
how is it going to six that does not
make any sense right
so this is why i put it here as six
what happens is that when the value of
total fingers is zero
it gives the value of minus one and
in python what we have is that if we
write
minus one of the list it will take the
last element
so the last element is the value number
zero
so that's why i put the image at the end
so it will take that minus one value
and whenever it is zero it will become
minus one and it will take the last
element which is the sixth element
so this is uh the results
so you can see here whenever it is zero
it gives us that a fist image which is
image number six so this is good
and we are pretty much done the only
thing we can do is we can add a
rectangle
to show the count so that it is a little
more
appealing you can say so here we can
write
cv2 dot rectangle
we will put in an image and then
we have to give it the uh the
points the starting point and the ending
point
uh 170 so i have tried out this before
so i know the values
that will work properly so i'm directly
inputting those
so then we can put the color let's say
green
and then we can write cv2 dot filled
so if we run this
uh you will see whenever we have our
image or whenever we have our detection
we get that green rectangle so this is
only coming when we have the hand
because it is in the if statement so if
we put it outside the if statement it
will
it will always appear but i prefer that
it
disappears whenever the detection is not
there
so then we are going to put the text we
will write cv2 dot
put text and inside that we will add our
image and we will change
the text to total fingers
and then we will give in the location
and then we have to give in the font
so we will pick the fonts
plain font and then we have to give in
the scale
we will keep it really big so we can see
two five five zero and zero and then we
will put
25 so this is the thickness
so let's try that out and we'll bring
in our hands and if we close it's zero
one two three four five
i will do it again one two three
four and five
one two three four five
so as you can see it works really well
and the detection is really great but
again if i use these two
uh two fingers it will still show me the
image of two
and if i let's say put these three up it
will still show me the three
default image that we have so if you
want to change these
you will have to put if statements for
each of these
you will have to have an if statement
rather than a loop
and you can define if this is the case
then this should be the image if this is
the case then this should be the image
so each of the fingers can be like a
binary so if that is
0 0 1 1 then you do this if it's 1 1
1 you do this 1 1 0 0 you do this
and so on so you can do it like that
hey everyone welcome to my channel in
this video we are going to create a
personal ai trainer
we will use the pose estimation running
on cpu
to find the correct points and using
these points we will get the desired
angles then based on these angles we can
find
many gestures including the number of
bicep curves
we will write the code in a way that you
will be able to find angles between
any three points with just a single line
of code
so here we are in our pycharm project
and you can see that this is the exact
same one that we used
in our previous video so we started off
with the
bare minimum code so you can see this is
all of the
bare minimum code that we require to run
our pose estimation
and then we created a module out of this
so this is that module which allows us
to create these projects
very quickly so today will be one of
these examples where we
create a project very rapidly so
then here is our awesome project so this
was the demo
of how you can actually utilize this to
run your module so these were the things
or these were the files that we created
last time
so if you haven't checked that video i
highly recommend
that you do go through that video before
you continue here
now today we are going to do the ai
trainer so we have a new folder here
called the ai trainer let's open that up
and let's check out the contents so
here we have a test image
so basically the idea is that we want to
find the angle
of any three given points so point
number one
point number two and point number three
so
this is actually explained here in the
summary
so what we will be doing is we will be
using these three points and based on
these three points we are going to find
the angle between these
two lines so that will tell us
how much angle we are at and based on
that we can do some calculations for the
gestures
or for the poster so that we can tell
the person
okay you have done this many curls so
what we will be doing is we will be
counting the number of curls
that a person has done you can apply it
to other techniques as well to see the
posture
whether they are using correct ones for
yoga or something like that
so the main idea is that we will do this
in two steps
the first one will be to find the angles
so
we will create a method where
we we can input any three points and it
will give us the angle
of these three points so this way we do
not have to
worry about getting other angles for
example if i want for the leg
i will have that information as well if
i want for the arm
and the shoulder i can have that
information as well for the elbow
and the wrist i can have that so with
one single line of code i will be able
to have
all of these different angles so i will
just have to specify the landmark number
for example uh for this arm it is 11
13 and 15 so i can say 11 13 15 and it
will give me that one
if i say 12 14 and 16
it will give me for this one so
for sorry for this one so this is the
idea that we will create this
method and the second part is where we
will try to find the angle
and no actually we will have the angle
and based on that
angle we will see how many curls did the
person do
so this is our idea so we will start off
with
this is by the way the video let me
bring it here
so this is the one we will be using
again
both of these images and videos i got
from pixels.com
so you can check it from there or you
can find these documents
in my website so you will find this
folder over there
so what we will do is we will right
click and we will create a new file
and we are going to call this let's say
our a ai
trainer project
so the first thing we will do we will
import our packages so we will write
here import cv2
then import numpy as
np and what else do we need we need time
so we will import that so all of these
packages we have imported earlier so
if you are new and you haven't seen the
previous video
you can go to settings python
interpreter and you can add
and here you can write opencv
dash python and you can hit install
and then you can write media pipe
media pipe and there you can install
so these are the two libraries that are
the most important ones okay so once we
have that we are going to import
our image and the video so here you can
see
we have the image not this one the test
image and the video
so we will be using the test image at
first
for the angles and once we have that
then we will use the video
for the curls now uh we will write the
while loop
anyway so that we don't have to switch
at the end we just can remove one line
and
it will convert to video so we will
write here first
that we have a video capture device so
we will write here
uh cv2 dot video capture and we will say
this
is the ai trainer
slash what is it girls dot
mp4 and then we will say
while true we are going to
check the success and the image
and we will say cap dot read and oh
and then we will say cv2 dot
im show we will write here image
image and then we will write
image and cv2 dot weight
key and layoff one so if we run this
we should get our video running so
let's run that and there you go
so as you can see this is quite a big
video it's quite huge we can
resize it we can write here image is
equals to cv2
dot resize and we want to give it a
specific one so we will write here
one two eight zero by seven twenty
so let's try that and there you go so
now this is good
and we are ready for the girls part but
as i mentioned before we are going to
use the image first
and later on we are going to use this so
we are going to comment this
and here instead we are going to write
image is equals to cv2 dot
i am read and then
we can read our image so
it will be a i trainer slash
what is it test dot jpg
so we can actually put it outside
so let's run that and there you go
so we are getting our image so we will
check the angle
of this and we will see how we can
calculate that okay so that is good
now we need to find our pose so to find
the pose
what we have to do is we have to import
our pose module
so here is our pose module that we did
in our earlier video
so here we have the class pose detector
we are going to use that to create an
object once we have the object we can
use
find pose to find the pose and then find
position
to get all the data in that list
so here we are going to say detector
the detector
is equals to oh i didn't import forgot
to import
so imports pause module
pose module as pm
and then we can write here pm dot
post detector and we do not need to give
any
inputs at this point so then we can come
down here
and we can write here that uh
detector dot find pose
and do we need to input anything
uh we need to put input the image and
then we
need to tell whether we want to draw or
not so by default it's true so we will
draw
and what else so do we need anything
back
uh no not really we can yeah we need the
image back
so let's run that and there you go
so now you can see okay this is not good
we need to put it inside
so that it's detecting again and again
there you go so now you can see it is
detecting the pose
and now we can try to find the angle
but how do we get the landmark values
so we can use the get position so we
will write here
nlm list is equals to detector
dot get position
wait why is it not showing detector dot
is it oh it's find position okay so
find position and then we will write
image and we don't want to
draw so we will write here false
i think there are only two arguments so
we can directly write false yeah
so that's fine so let's run that
actually we need to print to see if
we're getting anything
lm list and let's do that
and there you go so this is our list and
we can see we have all these 32 points
so that is good okay
so now we can uh first of all we need to
make sure that
we have a list where we have uh the post
detected otherwise it will give us an
error
so we can write here the length of our
lm list is not equals to
zero then we are going to do something
magical so what is the magic that we are
going to do
so now here the thing is that
we can write the code here but then it
will be for this project only
we can write here path for now so
that will be for this project only but
we don't want to do that
we want to we want to enhance our pose
module
by adding a method to it so this
pose class which is the pose detector
it will have another method that will
allow us to get the angle
of any three landmarks so
instead of giving the points for example
485
and 281 what we will do is we will say
we want to find the points between 3
4 and 5 and because it already has this
method
and it already has this list we will
make it an instant list
so that it is for that particular object
so
then we will not have to even input the
point value
we just have to input the number so we
need to know which
landmark numbers we are talking about
so how can we do that let's start by
writing our code
so the first thing we will do is we will
create a new method we will call it
find angle or angle
no find the angle because it's just one
angle
then we will give in our image um
the image the image is for drawing
so we will input that and then we will
need the three points so we will call it
p1 p2 and p3 so these are the three
point
uh landmarks that we need and then we
can have the flag
for drawing as always so
we will keep it as true
okay so now as i said instead of giving
in the points
we are just using the values so we are
using
value number four value number three you
can call them index
index number two three four so
these are basic basically index values
so what we need to do is we need to
get the values of the points
based on our index value so how can we
do that
so in the find position you can see we
have the lm list
so what we can do is here we can send
this lm list
back again to our object but that is not
a good way to do it
because we already have it we can just
use it internally
so we can write here self dot and now
this is part of that object
so we will write here self dot and we
will write here
self dot so now what we can do is
we can write here that our x1
and x1 and y1
is equals to self
dot self dot
lm list at
point number one so let's say we want
landmark number three
so that will give us this landmark
number three
but the thing is it has three things
inside it has
number three it has 485 and 281
so what we can do is we can slice it so
here we will write
we need for from point number one
till the end so it will take
this and this and it will ignore this
so then it will store it in x one and x
uh in y one
you can also do it like this so you can
ignore the first one
and you can you can remove this one and
you can
ignore the first one and you can take
just the
last two but uh let's do the first
method
let's do it like this and then
we are going to write here x2
y2 and then x3 and
white by three and here we are going to
write
point number two and point number three
now to make sure we are getting the
correct points
we are going to draw so here we will
write
if draw
we are going to write a circle so let's
just
copy because we are lazy
and we will just change this to x1
and x2 okay
so yeah that should be good
we can copy this
and we can make it x
wait what did i do x 1 x 2 why did i do
x 1 x
this should be y 1
i always make that mistake y 2 x 2 and
then
y 2 and then x
three and then y three okay
so that should give us but we didn't
call it
so we need to call it here so
we are going to write that detector
dot get angle or find
angle and we will give in our
image so now we need to give in the
points
so if we go to media pipe and we check
for the points
you can see that we want point number 11
13 and 15 and then 12
14 and 16 so based on
if we want right or left so the left one
is
the odd one so 11 13 and 15 is the left
one
so here i think the right one is visible
so we will use
the right one so 12 14 and 16
and the draw we will keep it as true
so now let's run this and see what
happens
and there you go so now you can see
these have turned blue
so we know that these are the ones that
we are using
uh should we decorate it more
or should we do it later let's do it now
so what we can do is
we can make it look a little bit nicer
uh just to make sure that we are using
these correct points because uh
at some point we are going to remove all
the other uh what you call
the detection the pose estimates so here
we are going to create
a bigger circle and let's put it
as 15 and let
put this as 10 and we will not fill it
and we will put the value of 2 here
and for the color let's put it as red
so here we are going to write 255
and we are going to write here
all of these as red um
yeah and then what else so we will copy
this
we'll paste it here and paste it here
we'll make it two and two and then
three and three so let's try that
there you go uh oh we forgot to remove
the filled
no we did remove the fill oh we didn't
do the
size we forgot to change the size
okay there you go so these are the three
points
and what else we can do the line as well
so let's do the line before that because
uh
the circles we want to draw on the line
so we will write here cv2 dot line
and the first line will be on the image
and
we will have two points and then we will
have
we will put the color of white so it's
really visible
and then we will put the thickness of
three
so here our first uh what do you call
points will be x1 and y1
and then the second one will be x2 and
y2
we will copy this and here we will have
what happened there here we will have
x3 so 2 will be common for both of them
one and three will be changing so let's
try this
uh nothing happens why didn't anything
happen
because i put this in the wrong place
this should be outside
okay there you go so now we have the
white line and so now we can go back
and we can make this false
so that we can just focus on these three
points and the rest will be gone so
there you go
so now we have these three points and we
want to know the angle
between these points so
we will go back to our module
and here now we need to find the angle
so
the angle finding is not actually hard
so
here we can write for example get the
land
marks and here we are going to write
calculate the
angle and then here we will write
draw well
you know it's written draw here and
we're writing draw here
very redundant but anyway so we will
write here angle
is equals to we are going to use math
so we will write here imports
import math so this is just basic
trigonometry so we don't have to worry
too much about this
so what we can do is we can write here
math
dot tan 2 sorry a tan 2
a tan 2 and then we have to give in y 3
minus y 2 and then
x3 minus x2
then we will subtract
and we will write here math dot a tan
2 and then we will write y1
minus y 2 and then we will write
x 1 minus x 2.
so again i'm missing some brackets
so that should be good so this will give
us our angle in radians so we can
convert it into
degrees so math dot degrees
and there you go
so if you have three points and you want
to find the angle between
the two lines the this is the method
this is the equation that you can use
so here we can simply write print angle
and we can see what exactly is our angle
okay uh what happened there so there is
a mistake
for sure it's the brackets yeah
and this is extra
so yeah i put one extra
my bad okay so here we are getting our
angle
87 which
makes sense like it is almost 90 degrees
you can see that
so 87.3 it's not bad
so what we can do is we can put this on
the actual text or the actual image so
that we can
see so we can write here cb2 dot
put text and we will write image
and we will write the angle but
let's convert it into integer
and then we will convert it into string
otherwise it will not accept and then we
will write here
uh the value so the position
so here we will write x2 so this is the
center point
so we have x1 and x2 these are the
further points
and x2 is the middle point so we want to
write the value
near the middle point so we are using
x2 but we don't want to write it exactly
at that position
so we can subtract like 20 from it and
then we can write y2 and we can let's
say
add 50 to it so we can change these
values if we are not
satisfied okay then we can write cb2 dot
font let's pick the plain one and then
we will write the scale
and the color so color let's
put purple and then we will write
the thickness
so let's run that there you go
so we are getting 88.87
so that's good uh the x is bad
so let's do
we did minus right so minus 50
let's see yeah it's
better now maybe let's convert this into
blue
that's more visible
now the background is a little bit black
so it's not that visible maybe red will
be more visible
or green
yeah red is not bad so 88 degrees
is what we are getting and sometimes
what happens is
that we get a negative value so for that
case we can write here
uh should we actually let's remove this
and for those cases we can write if our
angle
is less than zero then we will say our
angle
we want to add 360 to it so
360 minus whatever the value will be
so that will solve that problem
so now what we can do is we can use
any three points to find our angle
so let's say i want for this is for the
right one
so we can say here right right
arm let's say and then i can do the
exact same thing
with just one single line of code i can
write here left
arm and i will just change the values
11 13 and 15
and now you will see it will do for both
of them
and that is pretty amazing so it is
telling
the angle for both of them at the same
time
so uh the last uh the the one that is
hidden is not very clear so you cannot
rely on that angle
but the one that is here is quite good
so we can remove this
so now we can try this on our video
so for the video as i mentioned we want
to do it on the left arm rather than the
right
and by the way you can do it on the legs
as well so it it's up to you now which
three points you want to take for
example you can take 23
25 and 27 so it will tell you the angle
between
uh these two lines then you can use 24
26 28 it will tell you the angle
between these so it is up to you which
ones you want to use for your own
project but for now we will use the left
arm
for the bicep curls so now we will
remove this we will uncomment this and
we will remove
the image part and let's try
to see if we get the angle there you go
so now we are getting our angle and as
you can see
probably it's going to negative and all
so that's why it's
giving this value
so what we can do is we can find the
minimum and the maximum
and based on that we can check if it has
reached that point or not so
let's try to figure out the minimum and
maximum now the good thing is if you
click on the window
it will stop so we can
check our values very easily so here you
can see it's 338 but that's not the last
one
so here i saw 190 something
yeah 180 probably
or let's say 200 yeah 200 is not bad
or just to be on the safe side we can
keep it a little bit higher
like 220 or something like that so that
it goes to zero easily
and then over here we can see it goes to
300 something
so 340 but again
might not go always there so
3 30 maybe
20 or 310 i can see it goes again and
again
to 328
so it went to 340 340
oh it's going to 40. now it's 28
27 29 okay
so to be on the safe side we can we can
say that it is
um 20 right so or we can say 15.
so what we can do is we can convert our
range we want it from 0 to 100 we want
to know
how much curl uh we are at so the
percentage of curves so at the
zero point or at the 100 point so
what we will do is we will create a
percentage and we will
say that did we import numpy yes
so we will use numpy to convert our
range
so we will say numpy dot inter
interp and then we will given our angle
not range angle
oh we didn't get it back that's why it's
saying this angle
is equals to so i think i forgot to
return yeah so we need to return
return angle so
that will return our angle over here and
then we can use this here
angle is equals to
what else do we need so we need the
first range
so our range will be let's say 210
to 310 let's say
and we want to convert it into 0 to
100 so this is already 100 so we can
easily
just subtract but if we had a difficult
range you can use
this method so
that should be good so let's print out
this value
and we will print out the angle not the
angle the percentage
so or we can print the angle and the
percentage that would be
good to see are we printing anything
here
no okay that's good so we can run this
so here we can see
so it's zero going hundred percent then
going back to zero
then two hundred percent going to zero
hundred
zero excellent so now we can see that we
are getting the correct values
so we should not face any issues
because we have taken quite safe values
if you go too far
you might not get good results you have
to
check the trade-off between accuracy and
taking the risks of getting error okay
so then we are going to check
when are we reaching the
the first curl when are we reaching the
second we need to count
so here we are going to go up and we are
going to define two things
the first one will be count which will
be zero
and the other one will be direction
which will be zero
now we will have two directions
direction number zero and direction
number one
direction number zero will be when it is
going
up and direction number one will be when
it's going down
so we will consider a full curl only if
it does
both of these so it goes up and then it
goes down
to zero so from zero to hundred and
hundred to zero
so if we get that then we will consider
it as
first curve so we could do the other way
around but
i want to keep it like this where we
have
um the complete girl if we go back and
forth
the whole thing so we are going to write
here
that we want to check check
for the dumbbell
dumbbell curl
girls okay so
then we are going to write here that if
our percentage
is equals to 100
and then we are going to check if our
direction direction
is equals to zero so this is the first
direction it means we are going up
now you might say why didn't you just
write and here if
percentage is hundred and if direction
is zero
i will tell you why later there's the
reason
so then we are going to say count
plus equals 0.5 so
we will add 0.5 to the count so
if it's going up and it has reached 100
it will be 0.5 and then it's going down
and it reaches 0 then it will be 0.5 so
that will be a complete curve
so what i can do now is i can
change the direction so direction is
equals to 1
and then i can check here that if my
percentage
is equals to 0 and
my direction is equals to
1 then i will write
count is equals to plus is equals to 0.5
so the same thing that we did earlier
and then we will make the direction
one uh no we will make the direction
zero
okay so this will keep adding to our
count
and this way we will know which
direction we are moving and
how many counts uh did we have so far
so here we can remove this and we can
simply print the count
so we can write here print count
and let's see what do we get
so zero point five down one
one point five down two two point five
down three three point five down
four so excellent so if you
um okay let's just display it first and
then i can discuss
so we can display it like this cv2 dot
put text and we can write here image
and we can write our string so
we can write inside that
integer so if you want to directly show
the decimal places
so if you want to show the 0.5 count as
well
then you can keep it like this so you
can write simply count
but i don't like that uh or let's try it
now i will show you and then we will
change it
and then we will write here
let's say 50 and 100
and then we will write cb2 dot
font let's put the plain one 15
and then we will put 255
0 0 and then 25
actually these are very big values we
will put big values later on
but for now we just want to see if we
are getting the output properly
okay so what is the problem
it's not callable
is that the issue
oh okay i forgot to write
comma okay so here we are
getting 1.5 to 2.5
3 3.5 that is good so what i was saying
is that if you don't want that you can
simply write here
int and then you can put it like that
so if we see that now it's zero it
becomes one
two three
so it's up to you which one do you
prefer
okay so now that we have this we can
make it a little more appealing so
what we can do is we can first of all
add our
fps so we didn't add that earlier so we
can add it now
so we can write here c time is equals to
time
time dot time and then we can write
fps is equals to 1 divided by
current time minus the previous time
and then we will write our previous time
is equals to
current time and then
we will put the text so we can copy this
and we can paste it here and then we can
change it to
fps so
that should be good now
we need to put previous time as zero
over here okay so that will give us the
time
and we can comment this
to check the fps so there you go so we
are getting good fps
now this video is 1080p and we are
reducing the size of it
and that's why it's giving a lower frame
rate otherwise you will have a better
frame rate if you
because here we are resizing so if you
directly use maybe this size
or even lower you will get higher frame
rate
okay so then what we can do is we can
put
our what you call the number of count
in a box so let's create a box
so i have already checked the values of
this box
so i will directly input it so we will
write here cv2.rectangle
rectangle and we will put in our image
and we will put in 0 450
and then 250 and
720 so this is for a 1280 by 720
which is hd image so it is for that
so 255 and 0 and then
cb2 dot filled
so this will give us a green box and
what we can do is
we can uncomment this
and we can format it
and then here we need to change the
value let's put it as
45 and 670.
let's run that there you go uh okay we
need to change the size of this
so 15 and 25
25 okay
so there you go so now we are getting
this nice and big
so we can see what is happening that is
quite good
and it is giving us the angle do we need
the angle
uh no i don't like the angle let's
remove the angle from here
so let's run it again there you go so
now we are getting without the angle so
it looks good
now what else can we do okay let's put
the bar
so if you remember we did it in one of
the other videos for the volume gesture
control
so you can check that out as well it was
to control the volume
of a computer using your hand gestures
so we use the bar in that one as well so
here we are going to use the bar again
so for the bar first of all we need some
values so we will write here bar
is equals to np dot
interp and we will convert our angle
from the range of 220 to 300
uh not 300 310 and we will put it
as 650 and 100 so this is the maximum
value of our bar
uh no the minimum value of our bar and
this is the maximum value of our bar
because the opencv convention is
opposite so this is the minimum this is
the maximum
okay so why is not giving a space here
okay
so then we need to create that rectangle
so here
we can create that rectangle we will
copy
this because we are lazy we will copy
twice
and we will also put the text
okay so now we need to change the values
here
so the starting will be 1100
and then 100 then we have
one one seven five and we have 650
then we have what we call
1100 here
and then we have our bar value so
integer bar not bad bar
and then we have eleven
seven five and then six five zero
so for the text we will have our
percentage
so we will make a string
and we will write here
integer and then we will write our
percentage
and at the end we will write percent
so this we will display at 1175.
and the size will be four and four
okay so we can write here
that this is for our bar
draw bar and
let's say we write here
uh show or let's try draw
uh girl count
okay so then let's try it out
there you go but
[Music]
the bar value is not changing
what did we do wrong oh
so apparently the value of the bar is
not changing because it is filled
come on so this should be
let's say three and let's try that
yep so it goes down it goes up it goes
down
it goes up now one more thing we can do
is
when it reaches the zero or the maximum
position
we can change the color so that we know
it's
it's like when you reach a certain point
and or you press a button
it changes color so you can you kind of
get a feedback so it looks good
so that is the reason why we put an
if within an if so here
we are going to write color
is equals to by default we are going to
write the color as purple
and if it reaches we are going to change
the color
as green so we will put the color
as green so 2 5
5 and 0.
and the same thing we can do for our
zero if you want to change the color for
zero make it different than the other
ones
you can do that too but we are going to
keep it like that
so here we are going to
write
we are going to write here color and
then
here we are going to write color
and here we are going to write
color so all of them are same
so now it's green purple purple green
purple green green
yeah so that's how you can tell if you
have reached the correct point or not
so as you can see it works very well
and again if you want to use a webcam
you can simply
enter the value or the id number of your
webcam
and it should run pretty much the same
way just make sure that your face
is visible within the camera
and you are at a good distance
because a lot of this depends on the
face as well so if you are not
within the uh if your face is not in the
camera it will not detect properly
so that is pretty good
so i i had a hard time finding uh these
videos with bicep curls
so that's why i just had this one
but i will try to find some more but
yeah so that is the
idea the error is because the video ends
that's why it
gives this error it's not something that
we
made a mistake here
hey everyone welcome to my channel in
this video we are going to create
a virtual painter using ai we will first
track our hand
and get its landmarks and then use the
points to draw on the screen
we will use two fingers for selection
and one finger for drawing
and the best part is that all of this
will be done in real time
so the first thing we will do here is to
go to canva.com
and if you're not familiar with canva it
is basically a design tool it's an
online website
that helps you create all these
different designs for brochures
business cards flyers whatever you want
you can basically design here so this is
a free website so you can go and
start you can start by just signing up
so here we have
a canvas of 1280x720
so we are expecting our webcam to be of
this size that's why we
are using this size so the idea here is
that we are going to create a design
to actually make it look more appealing
and make it look more like a software so
this is up to you
if you want to skip this step you can do
that too there will be files to download
from my website
the ones that i already did so if you
want to skip you can go ahead and do
that too
but here we are going to start off with
a
rectangle and
what we will do is we can we can
put it on the side but the issue with
the side
is that it will be hard to select
different
elements so what we will do is we will
put the menu
on the top so our menu will be
here at the top now for the width
let's keep it at 100
100 is too small maybe 120
125 yeah that looks good
so then we can lock this
or let's change the color first so i
like this blue
or maybe this one yeah this one looks
better
so let's lock this so it doesn't move
around
then we are going to add let's add the
logo first
so i'm going to go to photos and
right here logo uh no
it's in upload my bad
so i have my logo here i'm going to
place it on the side
and yeah that looks about right
then we are going to add some brushes
so here we will go to the elements and
we will search for brushes
so let's write here brush
uh okay so these are strokes
we are not getting actual brushes here
we have
let's write paint brush maybe
yeah i think now we have better results
uh i want to look for something that is
free this is free
okay so maybe something else that is
free this is free as well
so i'm looking for something free so
that everyone can use
it not just the pro users
um
[Music]
maybe this one no it's pro this one is
free too
do we have a color of i think this one
is the best
okay let's keep it this way and if we
want to we can change it
later on so let's take
this part right about here
and we will zoom in and
maybe a little bit smaller
there you go so i think that looks good
now the good thing is that
most probably this is an svg file so we
can change the color for it
so let's say we want pink
what is that purple let's try pink
and what we can do is we can have
another one
that is a little bit bigger than this at
its back
so that will indicate that this has been
clicked
so we can put it okay let's change the
color first
we can put it as white or gray
or dark gray let's put it at the back
i think white will be better
okay i'm no designer i'm just
eyeballing this so i'm gonna put it as
whites
yeah okay so then what we can do is we
can copy
both of these and we can
paste them here so
somewhere in the middle and we can paste
another one
and then we need
an eraser so we don't need the last one
actually
the one at the back
or do we okay let's keep it let's keep
it for now
i will tell you why later on okay so now
we need an eraser
so let's write here eraser
okay this one is pro pro pro
this one is free
no not really
all of these are paid
oh this one is free
yeah i think that could work so
let's put that a little bit bigger
i think i'm putting it too big anyways
you can change the design later on
uh we are learning the concept here
uh or let's just make it a little bit
smaller
so i think that will be better
so we can grab these two and we can
place them here
this one in the middle
this one a little bit further
okay i think that is better and then we
can make this
a little bit smaller and there you go
so i think that looks good now what we
can do
okay these are not at the top to put it
at the top
here
okay so now what we will do is we will
change the color for these
so the first one is let's say pink the
second one let's say
is blue or
dark blue in between maybe
this looks weird okay let's
keep this as blue and then the last one
let's keep it as green
so these are the let's say three colors
that we want and
then what we will do is we will
this doesn't seem right i think at the
back
needs to go higher maybe
yeah maybe like this okay i'm going to
copy this
and we will paste it here
so we'll put it at back
and the same thing to the last one
okay so you can move it around with your
keys
your arrow keys so
maybe a little bit higher again you can
spend a lot of time on this but we are
going to skip that
we will not put a lot of effort here
just for a demonstration purpose but you
can of course go ahead and try a lot of
different things
so um now what we will do is we will
copy all of these
we will duplicate them so here you can
see
or let's change the size first so we
already know
that our size is 1280
by 125 so we will go to resize
and we will change this to 125
and we will copy and resize or you can
resize is up to you
i'm going to press resize so it will do
it on the same one
then i can unlock this and i can grab
all of this and i will scale it up
so it should fit perfectly because it is
the same size
there you go so this is the image that
we need
so we are going to copy this four times
because we will have a selection for
each one of these
so we can delete the selection for this
and the selection for this
and this is the first one so first one
this is the one selected the second one
this is selected
and for the third one we will have
this one selected and the fourth one we
will have the
rubber selected so here we are going to
it is whites let's
change this to let's change this one to
the same color
as this and
let's make it a little darker like
let's make all of them darker so
yeah and then let's make this
it's a black hmm that's too much
okay i think that is enough indication
so we just need an indication that that
has been pressed
so that should be fine so now what we
can do is
we can download all these four images
and the idea here is that whenever we
detect a click we are going to uh change
these images
so we will see which one do we need so
if we have clicked the first one
then we will change the image to this if
the second one is clicked we will change
the image to this
then the third one and the fourth one
which is the eraser
so at any given point only one of them
can be selected
so that's the idea so we can go and we
can write here
that this is our virtual painter let's
say
and we can download all of these
in jpg or png whatever format you want
let's do it jpg and we can download all
of these
so here i am in the pycharm project now
this is the same project that we have
been using for the hand tracking
for the finger counter for the hand what
you call volume control
so we have done quite a bit of projects
earlier than this
so this is the exact same uh
what do you call project and you can go
to
file settings and you can see that we
have already installed
our media pipe and we have already
installed opencv
but if you are new you can go to the add
button you can write here
opencv dash python
and you can install this and then you
can go to mediapipe
mediapipe is the google library that we
will be using for hand tracking
so you can download and install this
so this is the main idea now what we
will do is first of all we will right
click this
and we will open it up in the explorer
now once we are in our project we are
going to create a new folder
and we are going to call it
header so we will have our header images
in here
so these are our images that we
downloaded so i will
copy all of this and i will paste them
here
and now you can see that these are our
header files
so we have a total of four header files
so when we go back to our pycharm
project you will see that we have a new
folder by the name header
and we are going to use that for our
images so then we are going to right
click and we will create a new
python file and we will call this
virtual painter
so now we are going to import our
libraries so we will write here import
cv2
import numpy as np
and then we will need imports time
if we want to show the frame rate and
then we will also need imports
os because we need to access these files
so we will need that
what else we also need our hand module
so we will write here
import hand tracking module
as htm
so this will be our hand tracking module
now if you are not familiar with this if
you haven't watched the previous
uh tutorial then make sure you go ahead
and look at that because this is the
tutorial
in which we went step by step and we
created this
hand tracking module so this is very
important
this basically tracks the hand so if i
run this
you will see if i right click here
this should open up my webcam
and if i bring in my hand you can see it
tracks
the hand so this is the idea of the hand
tracking module
and based on these values we are going
to
do some painting okay
so now first of all we are going to
import our images so that is the first
thing we are going to do we will write
here
that our folder path
is equals to header
so these are the header images and we
are going to say that
my list is equals to os dot
list directory list directory
and then we will get the name of
all our folder uh path files
so this is the idea if we print this out
if we print my list you will see that
we get all these uh
images name so here you can see one dot
jpg
two three and four so what we have to do
is we have to import them so that we can
use them later on to overlay
on the top so here we are going to write
for image path in
my list my list
we are going to loop and we are going to
import
so we will see that our image is equals
to
cv2.im read and we are going to
read from a string and that will be
the folder path slash
the folder
the image path so this will be
our complete path that we need to read
from
and then we are going to store it in a
list
so let's call this list overlay
list so this will have all the images
that we want to overlay
so we will write here overlay dot append
and we want to append our image
okay so this will overlay our images
uh no it will import all our images now
what we can do is we can print the
length of our overlay
list so we can see that whether we have
imported all of them correctly or not
so let's run that
so we have imported indeed four so that
is good
so far and next what can we do next
next we can run our webcam
and then once we have our webcam we can
simply overlay
one of these images by default so we can
call our image
let's say header and we
are going to give it an initial value we
will say that over list
at 0. so now this is our image
so whenever we get our original image we
are going to overlay this
on top of that okay so this
is good for now what we can do next is
we can
create our loop and we can run our
webcam
so here we are going to write cap is
equals to
cv2 dot video capture
video capture and we will say that
device number one
now you should write device number zero
because i have multiple cameras i'm
using one
then i will write cap dot set now this
is important
because we want the exact same size we
want one two eight zero
by 720 so we have to make sure that the
width and the height
are exactly the same so we are going to
write
1280 by 720 then
we are going to write here while true
we want to run our webcam and we want to
get our images
so we will write here that the success
and the
image is equals to cap
dot read and then
we are going to um okay let's just
display it first
so cb2 dot weight key
is 1 and we have cv2 dot
i am show i will say image and
image so
that should be enough so let's run it
we have an error
oh i wrote i am read no no no i am sure
what happened there
okay so there you go so this is our
image and you can see my hand
so what we will do we are going to
overlay our image now so how can we do
that
so we can simply write that
our image so you might think it's a
little bit difficult but it's not
it's very easy because our image is a
matrix we just need to define
where is the location of this new image
so we will slice it
so here we are going to say that our
height is from 0
to 125 because we know that the image
size is 125
and then the width we are going to say
is from zero
to one two eight zero so
at this region we are going to say our
image is equals to header
and that's how simple it is so if we run
this
there we go so now you can see that we
have our
image and on top of that we have
overlaid
our first image now this is good because
by default
we want our first paint
brush selected which is the pink one
so we are already up to a good start
so here we can write that
we are setting the
header image set
thing the header image okay
so this is good and now we can just
separate this because we are going to
write our code over here
so what else can we do
now the next step is
before we go into the details of the
project
let's split it up into pieces so first
of all we will
import the image okay so that's the
first step
we have pretty much already done that uh
there is another thing we need to do i
will tell you later
this is the first step let's write it
here one
then the second step
is that we want to find the landmarks
so find hand landmarks
so this can be easily done with our hand
tracking module so that should not be an
issue
then number three is basically
checking which fingers are up so
check which fingers
are up now this is because we want to
draw
when one finger is up which is the index
finger
and we want to select only when
two fingers are up this will allow us to
easily move around the canvas without
painting
so when our two fingers are up it will
not draw anything
if we want to draw we have to put one
finger up
the index finger so this will allow us
to
easily navigate through the canvas
then we have the selection mode so
we will check here at the fourth stage
we will say if selection mode
which is when two fingers are up
two fingers
are up then we have to
what do you call we have to select not
draw
then in the fifth one we have to check
if
we have the drawing mode mode
when uh index
finger is up so
this is the idea now
let's go on to the next parts
actually do we have a next part no
so this is pretty much it we have five
different steps
we are going to go step by step and see
how we can achieve
each one of these so the first thing is
that
for importing image it is pretty much
done the only thing we have to do is we
have to flip the image so we are going
to flip horizontally
this is because when you are drawing
if you want to draw on the right side
then
when you move to the left it will draw
on the right so to
flip the image we are going to right
here
flip and we will write image
and we want to flip in the first
selection
now this will allow us to solve that
problem
so let's try that
so now the image is flipped so if i go
on the right side it's going to the
right if i go on the left it's going
to the left so it will be easier to draw
because it will be more intuitive
now the second step here is to find the
landmarks now the landmarks we can find
but we need to import first so we are
going to write here
that our detector is equals to
hand tracking module dots hand detector
and then we are going to give in uh
detection confidence
so this is up to us what value do we
want to
use but we are going to keep a high
confidence
because we want it to be
uh good in painting we don't want
a lot of mistakes here and there so by
default it's 0.5
we have changed it to 0.85
then over here we are going to say that
our image is equals to
detector dot find hands
and we are going to send in our image
so this will draw on our image and it
will
uh detect the hand so let's try that
there you go so now we can see it's
detecting properly
so that is good
the next step is to get all the landmark
positions so we are going to write here
landmark list
is equals to detector dot find position
and we will write image and we do not
want to draw
so draw is equals to false
and then we can check if the length
of our landmark list is not
equals to zero not equals to zero
then we are going to do something let's
print
the lm list
so let's try that
so let's see if it prints there you go
so it's printing the landmarks if i move
around
if i go out of the image it does not
print anything if i come back in
it prints the what you call
landmarks so that is good
so now that we have this we need to know
the the tip points of our index finger
and the middle finger so what we will do
is
we will call the
index finger tip as x1 and y1 so we will
say
x1 and y1
is equals to lm list at point number
eight
so this is the landmark eight
so here you can see this is the landmark
eight
and we have the value of 729 and 396 for
example
in this case so this is the tip of our
index finger
so here i can write
tip tip of
index and middle
finger zoom okay so
then uh as you can see it is basically
the first and the second element not the
zero one
so here we have to write from one
till the end so we will write it like
this
so it will grab only these two
so we are unpacking them here so x1 and
y1
so we will do the same thing here for
the middle finger
and for the middle finger we will write
x2 and y2
and the number for middle finger is 12
so that should be good
so now that we have our landmarks
and everything is good now we need to
check
which finger is up so
this thing we did in our one of our
previous videos
and that was i believe
in the finger counting project so if you
remember here if we go back here
so here is the code that when it is
thumb
it will check if it is up or down
then it will check the rest of the four
fingers if they are up or down
so and then it will give us the total
finger count
and it will also give us the list
where is the list yeah the fingers is
basically the list
which will tell us which of these are up
and which of these are down
so what we can do is we can pretty much
copy paste
this part and we can create
a method in our hand tracking module so
earlier we did not
do it as a method in our class but this
time around because we are using it
again and again
it is better to create a class rather
than putting it in
different projects every time so
this is our hand tracking module we are
going to open that up and you can see
right now we have only two methods
find hands and we have find position
so next we are going to put another
method
and that will be called fingers up
so we will write here def
fingers up
so that will tell us which of the
fingers are up
so we will go to our finger counter
project
and from here we can copy so
we have from fingers
till this part i think that should be
enough
so we will copy that and here we are
going to
paste it so what we are doing is we are
first creating a list
called fingers and then we are basically
checking
if the tip of our
thumb is on the right or on the left
so that will tell us if it's open or
closed and then for the fingers we are
checking if the tip of the finger
is above uh the other landmark
which is two steps below it or it is not
so if it is below that then it means it
is closed if it's above that it means it
is
open so it is storing the value of 1
when it is open it is storing the value
of 0 when it is closed
but why are these errors over here
these errors are here because it does
not recognize
tip ids and tip ids was something that
we declared
over here so this is the list so we can
copy that
and in our module because we know that
it will not going to change
the tip numbers the tip ids they are not
going to change we are going to write it
in our initialization so we will write
here self
dot tip ids is equals to this
so now if we go back and instead of just
using
tips we use self.tips it should work
so we will do that and there you go
so that works but now the lm list it
doesn't
uh recognize it because we did not
define it
as a self as an instance so we need to
write here self dot lm list
and i can copy that self again
and we can paste it here
we can paste it here so we can paste it
here we can paste it
here and here and here
so what happened now was that not only
we are returning this lm list when we
find the positions
we are also storing it so that if we
want it
in our other functions or our other
methods we can use it as well
so we do not need to send it out and
then receive it back again
internally it is available for us to use
okay so that should be good and if we
just return these fingers up it should
give us
if the fingers are up or not which of
them are up or not
so we can just return the fingers
and if we go back to our let's close the
finger counter
if we go to our virtual painter here
we are going to ask we will say that
detector dot fingers
up fingers up
and do we need to send something in
no not really so that is good we don't
need to send anything
and we can simply receive the values
in the variable or the list fingers
so let's print that out so fingers
and let's remove the previous prints
so let's run this and see what happens
so something is out oh it needs to be
inside this my bad
okay so this is our image
i will bring in my hand oh nothing is
happening
why is that okay so it takes a little
bit
uh to detect now you can see uh
how many fingers are there
uh okay the issue is i will tell you
what the issue is
for the thumb it's showing one when it
is open
when it is closed and 0 when it's
open because we are not checking the
left and right
so this is an issue that needs to be
solved more precisely
but for now we'll just change this
what was it before it was greater than
less than so by writing less than it
will solve the issue for now
but later on we do have to fix this so
i'm not going to fix it now
for this one but in this case you can
only use your right hand to draw
so if you use your left hand it will be
an issue
actually it won't be an issue because we
are not using the thumb at all
but it will give you wrong values so
here you can see the thumb
you can see two of them then three then
four so you can see all of these fingers
they are being detected properly
so now if i do this i should be able to
select
any of these and then if i do
if i do this i should be able to draw so
this is the main idea
so we need to check uh
now we know that which fingers are up
now we need to check if it's selection
mode or it is
drawing mode so how can we do that that
is very simple
let me bring that in because i will
forget again
okay so now we need to check if
uh the second oh no the first elements
so we have fingers at
first and fingers
at second if both of them are up
this means if both of them are true then
it means
it is selection mode so we will print
here say
selection
mode and
if that is not the case
we will write here
then we will write here that this is
equals to
false we only have the index finger up
then we will say drawing
mode so this is the idea
now what we do after that is a different
story but for now we just want to check
if it is able to understand this or not
so let's try that
we should remove the previous print
let's remove that let's run this
so this is selection mode because two
fingers are up
and now it's drawing mode so now it's
working very well
we can see when it is so when it is
nothing it doesn't do anything
when for detection you have to make sure
uh a lot of the image or a lot of the
hand is available in the image
so yeah so this drawing mode we can draw
this is the selection mode and
everything is good so far okay
so the next step what we can do is
we can uh change or we can draw
some circle around it so here if it is
selection mode
let's draw a rectangle so we are going
to write here cv2
dot rectangle and we are going to write
our image and then we are going to write
that we want from x1
till y1 minus
let's say 15 we want to go above
because we we are creating uh let's say
a rectangle using two points
so we don't want to just give those
points we want to
make it a little bit higher and a little
bit lower
so then we are going to use x2
and y2 and this time we will make it
plus 15.
so then we will give it a color so let's
say 2550255 this is purple
and then we will say cb2 dot fill
now we are drawing a rectangle here
because we are going to draw a circle
when it is time to draw so for the
circle
we are simply going to write here
cb2 dot circle
and we are going to give in our image
and we are going to draw
from x1 and y1 so we will write here
x1 and y1 and then we are going to
say 15 and the draw color again 2 5
5 0 2 5 5 and then we are going to write
cb2 dot filled
so this will be a visual indication of
when we are in selection mode
and when we are in drawing mode so
for selection it will be rectangle for
drawing it will be
circle so let's try that out so here it
is
rectangle and then
if we do this it becomes circle
so here the detection is not that good
but still
you can see
the rectangle is very small 15 is not a
good value
let's make it
25 and 25.
yeah now it is better so here i can say
it is selection mode
and here i can say it is drawing more so
it will be easy for us to detect
so my hand should be really back and
then i
should be able to draw easily but
because i'm near to the computer
so it's a little bit difficult to do it
this way
but it should work fine so far
we have done well okay so we have the
selection mode now and we have the
drawing mode
so let's work with the selection mode
first what we have to do now is we have
to check
if we are at the top of the image
now if we are at the top of the image we
are going to
change our uh image or
selection mode based on the location so
first of all we will check
if y1 is
less than 125 so this was the value
of our header so if we are in the header
then we are going to do something so we
will say that
if our value is between
250 if our x1
is between 250 and 450 then it means
it is clicking the first one so here
let me just write it here checking
for the click so that is what we are
doing here
so we will write here that if this is
the case then our header
is equals to overlay list
at zero so that's the first one
so by default it is the first one
because
we are using it here the value of header
is already where is it
yeah it's already the first one
then we are going to copy this and we
are going to paste it down here
and we will write that else if
else if the value is between 550
and 750 so these values i have checked
before
so if it's not the same we can change
a little bit so then it is 750
then it should be overlay list one
and then we are going to copy this we
will paste it here
and then one more time so we have a
total of four
so here it will be 800
to 950 and this will be
1200 and one zero five zero
so this will be two and this will be
three okay
so let's try that out so if we move
around we should be able to
select so if i go up
you can see it selects if i go here it
selects
if i go here it's an x so wherever i go
it selects the correct one and
the visual indicator is quite nice so it
tells us which one did we select
and if i go with one finger it's not
going to do it
because this is the drawing mode in the
selection mode we can select
okay so that is the difference here
so now we are able to select properly so
that is quite good
next we are going to change the color
so whenever we select something we want
to
indicate that the color has changed so
here for example for the drawing circle
or even for the rectangle
we want to change the color for it so
what we will do is
we will declare a color we will
go up here and over here we are going to
say
now the first image is for purple so if
we go to the header
and we see the first image it is for
purple or you can say pink
whatever color you want to anyways so we
are going to say that by default
our draw color color
is equals to purple
so whenever the value is selected
another value is selected we are going
to change this draw color
so and we will use it to actually draw
so instead of putting a random color for
the rectangle
and for the circle this is the color
that we are going to draw
and let's draw it after we have
checked for the click okay
we will put it here is it in the if no
it should be here okay so
what can we do now is that we can change
this color individually so here we will
say that
draw color is equals to
for this case it should be purple so it
should be two five five zero two five
five
and for the second one it is blue
so it is b g r
so this should be on and this should be
off
and then we have green
so b g r so this should be 0 this should
be 2 5
5 and this should be zero and then
for the eraser we will just make it
black
so black will erase everything so we
will make it zero zero zero
two five five two five five two five
five is one and zero zero zero
is black so
let's run that
let's try this so here our color is
purple
and both of them are purple we go to
selection mode
and now it's changed to blue you can see
for both of them it's changed to blue
we go to green and now you can see it's
changed to green
right so and if we go to the eraser it's
changed to black
so we can erase it for the black
actually
we can make an exception for the black
because
for erasing normally the tool is quite
bigger
but again we will discuss that later so
now this is done so
the selection mode is done we are able
to select our color
and it changes the color that is perfect
now what we need to do is we need to
draw
so we already know when we are in
drawing mode
we now need to draw based on our points
okay so now the easiest method and this
is
one that i have been using before as
well because it is very simple
whenever you are learning a new concept
you should go with the simple
thing rather than the most advanced or
complicated one
so earlier what i did was i created
using
uh simple points so
whenever you have a point you just draw
that single
circle and then whenever you move the
finger you draw the circle there as well
but the issue with that is whenever you
have
a rapid movement it will not draw
continuously as a line
it will have some gaps so that is not a
good way to draw
so what we will do now is instead of
drawing just a circle
we are going to draw lines but the issue
with lines is that we need a starting
point and we need an
ending point so here whatever current
position we are in
we just have that single point so we
need to know the previous point as well
once we know those both points then we
can simply draw a line
so let's draw that so here we are going
to write
that our cv2 dot
line and we are going to draw on our
image
and where exactly do we want to draw we
are going to draw
at our x previous position and
x y previous position and then
the new position which is x1
and y1 then
we are going to say which color do we
want to draw it with
we are going to say the draw color
and then we are going to give in the
thickness
so here we can declare a variable we can
say it
we can say that it is brush thickness
and if we want to change it we can
change it from the top here
so here we can create our variables
and we can write here that let's say our
brush thickness is
15 so we can easily change it
up and now we have the
x and the y previous so we will go
up here and we will declare that the x
previous and the
y previous are zero and zero
and then we will go down here
now the issue here is that at the very
first iteration
at the very first frame we will not have
any
xp and yp we will have the value of zero
zero
so it will draw a line from zero zero to
whatever the point you are
at and that will look really bad so this
should not be the case
so how can we fix it we can fix it by
writing here that if
our xp our xp is equals to 0
and our yb is equals to
zero it means it is the very first frame
that we have detected the hand or we are
starting to draw
then we are going to say that xp and
yp is equals to x1 and y1
so instead of putting 0 0 we are saying
whatever value
you are at draw exactly at the same
point so instead of drawing a line it
will just draw a point
so the very first time we
see our finger it will just draw a point
instead of a line
after that it will keep drawing as a
line so whenever we
have the new points we are going to say
that our x p
and y p is equals to our
x1 and y1 so these are our previous
points
so it will keep updating those
so hopefully that was clear now
let's try to run it and see if it draws
so here if i do this
it is drawing but it
is removing at the same time so as you
can see
it is drawing something but it is
removing if i go really fast
then you can see it is drawing so this
means
that our image is updating every
iteration
so we cannot draw on our actual image
so if we want to do that we will have to
uh
do something else i will tell you what
that something is later on
but for now we need to create a new
canvas on which we can draw
so what we will do is we will go up here
and at the very top we are going to
create a new image
and we are going to call it image
canvas and this will be the canvas on
which we will draw
so we are using numpy to draw our canvas
and we will use the zeros method and the
size is 720
by one two eight zero they use heights
before the width so we are writing it
like this and it has three channels
because we want colors
and it is unsigned uh unsigned integer
of eight bits
which means it will have 0 to 255 values
so that is pretty much it and now
instead of drawing on our original image
we are going to draw on the canvas so
where did it go here so we will copy
this
and we will paste it here and we will
say image canvas
and we will show the image canvas as
well
canvas okay so let's try that
so now we should have two images so this
is the image canvas
and this is the original image i will
keep this at the top
and if i if i bring in my hand and if i
draw
now you can see it draws and that is
very
very satisfactory okay
so this is the idea but now the thing is
it's not drawing here
which is fine if you want to you can
draw there as well and i will show you
how to do that
but before we go there let's try out uh
different colors so that we know that it
is working well
so i will keep this in the front but
it will be hard to see okay let's try to
put it here on the side
and i will try to
run that okay so this is a selection
mode i will select blue
and now i will draw with blue then we
have the
uh green mode the selection mode and
then i will draw with green
now i want to show you something else if
i don't put this part
if i don't put the first frame condition
what it will do is it will draw a line
from the very start so if i bring it
here
uh okay this is very annoying uh we need
to fix this first
okay let's say i am
here is my hand and then i start drawing
there you go so did you see it started
from the zero zero point
and it drew all the way to the current
point
so whenever you have uh the new points
let's say i go to the blue one and i
select that
you will see that okay not now but
in the previous one you saw that
whenever you
have the first first frame then it will
create this problem so
we are going to open that up so that we
don't have this issue
okay next we can also try the erasing
part
so the black one should erase whatever
we have drawn earlier
but what we can do is we can make it a
little bit bigger because if it is
bigger it is easier to erase
so let's first select
so let's draw
and now i will go to the eraser and i
will
come here and you can see it is erasing
but this is not very good because it's
very small
so what we can do is we can have a
special condition for the erasing
so we can write here that if
the draw color is equals to
0 0 0 then
we will have the size different
so here we will copy this part
uh actually we will copy both of these
and here we are going to write that
instead of the brush thickness
it is the eraser thickness so we will
write here eraser
and we will also write here that this is
eraser thickness
so we will go up and here we are going
to write
eraser thickness
is equals to let's say 50.
so it will be easier to erase and
here we can simply write
else we do this
so that should be good so if we have the
eraser tool now
so let's draw
now let's go to the eraser tool and
it's a little bit hard for me because
i'm sitting very next
to the webcam and there you go so i can
erase now very easily
and all of this will get very very nice
and very very good looking
once we do it on the original image the
only thing is that we have two images
now and it is very hard to see what is
happening
so now all we need to do is we need to
put it on the original image so we need
to draw on the original image
so how can we do that we cannot draw on
the original image because it refreshes
every time
so instead of doing that we are going to
add our two images
so what we can do is we can go down here
so here what we can do is we can write
here that
image is equals to cv2 dot
uh add weighted
and then we have to give in our image
the first image
and then we give in the value 0.5 let's
say
and then we give in the second image
which is image canvas
and then we given the value let's say
0.5
so this will add these two images and it
will blend them
so let's try that out
there is a argument missing
there you go so if i
draw you can see now it is drawing
again i need to go back a little bit
okay so now you can see it is drawing
when the hand is really at the back like
this it will draw well
but because i'm very close to the pc and
the camera
it is hard for me to do this i can go
back a little bit and there you go
but the issue here is that this does not
look very good i can change these values
but still it will be a blend it will not
be an
actual uh merging of the images it the
colors will not be that bright
there will be a transparency on it so if
you don't want that
what can you do now it is a little bit
complicated
but if you break it down it is very
simple
so what we will do is we will write here
uh let's where is the statement
right here okay so we need to go here
and we will write here first of all
we are going to create a gray image so
we will write here image gray
is equals to cv2 dot cvt
color and we are going to say that
image canvas and
cv2 dot color
underscore
bgr to gray tr
to gray so we are
converting it into gray image you might
be wondering wait why are we converting
it to gray image
i will explain in a bit then we are
going to convert it
uh into a binary image
then we will write here
image inverse is equals to
now we are creating we are converting
this into a binary image
and we are also inversing it what does
that mean i will explain as well
cv2 dot threshold
and image gray and we are going to write
50 and 255
and then cv2 dot threshold
binary inverse
so the idea basically is that
we want let me actually run it so you
can see better
so let's say i draw something
let's say i drew this and now i have
this image
so what i want to do i want to convert
this image
into black and white so wherever
i have black i want it to be white
and wherever i have this colored image
i want it to be black so what this will
do is
it will create a mask with all this
white
and only this region as black
and then i will go to this image
and in this image i will make all of
this black
and then i will merge this image
with this previous image
with the black area so it will overlay
these two
so i know it sounds a little bit
complicated
but you will see how it works so we
first of all we are creating that
inverse image
so that all that region where we drew uh
it is black
then we are going to write here that our
image inverse
is equal to cv2 dot cvt color
and we are going to write that our image
inverse
is basically cv2 dot
color color underscore
gray to bgr now we are converting it
back because we
want to add it to our original image so
we cannot add it if they are
not the same dimension you cannot add a
gray image to a
colored image so we need to make sure
both of them have three dimensions
then we are going to do image is equals
to
cv2 dot bitwise and
and we are going to add our original
image with the
inverse image image inverse
and then we are going to add our image
is equals to
cv2 dot bitwise or
and then we are going to write image and
image canvas
so again this might be a little bit
confusing but let's see the results
and i will go step by step and explain
it as well
so now here you can see i can draw
oh it went down here you can see i can
draw easily
it's not updating this value it seems
yeah okay it's not updating the value
okay so this is drawing on the canvas
now which is good
but actually on the original image but
the issue is
that it's drawing this straight line
whenever it is detecting
again so what is happening is that
whenever the hand is detected we should
put this x p and y p as zero
so we will copy this part and whenever
the hand is detected
then we will make it zero
actually no whenever the hand is
detected no no no
whenever we start drawing again so yeah
whenever we start drawing again
or whenever we have a selection
whenever we have a selection then we are
going to do
that
okay let's try that
yeah now it's starting from the right
position
instead of a random position
there you go so that is good so let me
explain
what is happening at the back so first
of all we have our gray image
and then we are converting it into an
image inverse
so let me display that image inverse
so this is our inverse image so wherever
i draw something it is going to draw but
with black area so let's try that
so as you can see it will draw with that
black area
right so that is the idea
then the next step is that we add these
images
so we are adding with and we are adding
the image inverse
and the image so let me show you
how that looks like so i will
remove this part
and we will run it
we will see here that when we draw
you will see that now it is showing us
black region wherever we drew
so all we have to do now is we have to
add this image
to this image so when we add this
because here we have colored part
here it's black here we have colored
part and here it's black
so if we do an or operation between
these two
it will give us our final image so here
we were doing an and operation with the
original image
and the image inverse here we will do an
or operation
to add these two up
and there you go so now it's moving
around
and the flickering you can improve if
you have a better detection
if you don't have a lot of noise so
again uh it cannot be
completely uncontrolled environment yeah
the environment should be a little bit
controlled
to have some good results so if i go
back
you can see i can draw a few things and
then if i go to the eraser
if i go to the eraser and i select
the eraser it will rub quite a bit
again my conditions are not very well
but
you can get the idea
and if i want to increase the size of
the brush or the
paint or whatever i can change it from
here i can make this 100
for the eraser thickness and
it will erase better so here
if i draw something
and then i can do this
and i can go to the eraser and then i
can
erase you can see how that's
how simple that is
hey everyone welcome to my channel in
this video we are going to create an
ai based mouse controller we will first
detect the hand landmarks
and then track and click based on these
points
we will also apply some smoothing
techniques to make it more
usable so here we are in our pycharm
project
and we have created it by the name ai
virtual mouse
so what we have here is the hand
tracking module
now if you have not been following we
have written this module
from scratch so from the very
beginning from the very first project we
have
uh added a lot of different methods to
this
particular uh class so now the thing is
that in our previous project we added
the fingers
up method and the fine distance method
and this will allow us to very easily
create
this new project so we will have a look
at that how we can do that and this file
of course will be available
online on my website so a lot of you ask
how do you access the code on the
website you have to log in and you have
to enroll
to get access and of course it is free
just enroll
and you will get the access now
if you have not been following you have
to go to file
settings and you have to go to the
interpreter
and you have to add the open cv open
cv python and we have to install it
and then we also have to install media
pipe
through which we will get all this hand
tracking functionality
so media pipe
and we are going to hit install
okay so now both of these are installed
and we can hit
ok so the first thing we will do we will
go
and create a new python file
and we will call it ai
virtual mouse project
okay so what we will do is we will first
import cv2 then we are going to import
numpy as np and then we will import
our module which is hand
hand tracking module as htm
and then we are going to imports
import time now apart from all of this
that we have been doing earlier as well
what we will do is we will also add a
new library
which will allow us to move around with
our mouse
so with the python script we will be
able to move our mouse we will be able
to click on it
there are a lot of these that you can
use the one we are going to use is
called
auto pi so we are going to hit install
on that so
an error occurred so let me check
again if we can install it
okay so he was giving an error earlier
but then i
clicked on it again and it installed
fine
so we can close this and we can go back
and now
we can also import pi
okay so the first thing we will do is we
will run our webcam to see everything is
working so we will write here
cap is equals to cv2 dot video capture
and we are going to write that our video
id
is one now you will use zero if you have
one camera i have multiple so i'm using
one now the second thing is that
we have to have a fixed width and height
so we cannot leave
it to the default of the camera so we
need to
change our width and height so we will
write here cap dot set
and the prop id for width is three
then the prop id for height is 4
so we will make it 480. so that's how
you can
define the width and height uh actually
what we can do is we can put them in
variables because we need to use them
later on as well
so let's declare our variables over here
so we are going to write here that our
width
of the cam and the height of the cam
is equals to 640 by
480 and we can just
input these values here so this is the
height of the cam
and then we can simply go let's remove
this and then we can simply go
and write while true
we are going to say success
and image is equals to cap dot read
and we are going to get our frame value
so once we have this frame value
then we are going to say cb2 dot im show
and we will say that our image and then
i mg and then cv2.weight key
and one so this is pretty much that we
have been doing
in all our projects so let's run this
and see if it works
there you go so now you can see my
webcam and there is my hand
so that is all good so next what we can
do is we can add our detector for the
hand tracking
but actually let's discuss what are the
steps that we are going to take today
to create this project so the first step
will be
uh let's put some numbering as well so
it is easier to remember
so the first step will be to find the
hand
landmarks so that will be the first step
then the second step will be to get the
tip of the
index and the middle finger so the idea
is that if we have just the index finger
then the mouse will move
if we have the middle finger up as well
then it will be in clicking mode
so if it is in clicking mode and if the
distance
between the two fingers is less than a
certain value
then we will detect it as a click so you
can bring your fingers together and it
will click
so in that mode we are not going to move
the mouse but
in the index mode where we are moving
uh that is the only mode in which we
will move
so what we can do here is that
our second uh what do you call
our second step will be to get the tip
tip of the index and
middle fingers so once we have the
tip of the index and middle finger what
we will do is we will check
which of these fingers are up so we will
write here number three
check which
fingers are up then
in the fourth step based on this
information
we will check if it is in moving mode so
we will write here
only index finger
which means it is in moving
mode so we will move our mouse
and if it is in moving mode then
we are going to
then we are going to convert our
coordinates
the units now why do we need to convert
because our webcam will give us a value
of let's say 640 to 480.
so for my screen i have a full hd which
means
920 by 1080 so we need to convert these
coordinates
so that we get the correct positioning
okay so then
okay it's bringing it back we can change
that later
then we will add another step to
actually smooth in the values
so why do we need to do that so that it
is not very
uh jittery it doesn't flicker a lot so
we will write here
smoothen values
so we will smoothen these values and
once that is done
we can simply move our mouse so move
mouse
okay so this might seem a lot but it
these steps are very easy some of them
are single lines some of them just two
lines so don't worry about these
then number eight will be to
check if we are in clicking mode so when
both index and
middle fingers are up
then it is clicking mode
so once it is clicking mode we will
find the distance between these fingers
so we will find distance
this tends between
fingers and if the finger
is if the distance is short then we are
going to click
so we will write here click mouse
if distance short
so these are the 10 steps we have to
follow and the 11th and 12th
step is fairly easy so the 11th step
is the frame rate to see if we are
getting a decent amount of frame rate
and the 12th step is to display
so we have already done this uh display
thing
so we do not need to do anything more in
that
now what we can do is we can go on to
the frame rate the frame rate is very
simple as well
we have done this quite a lot of times
by now
so we will simply write time.time
and then we are going to write fps
is equals to 1 divided by c time
which is the current time minus the
previous time
and then we will write that the previous
time
is equals to the current time
and then we will write cb2 dot put text
image then our string
which will we will first convert it into
integer and then we will write
our fps and then we are going to write
the position
so we will write 10 and let's say 50
or let's say 20 and 50. then we will
write cv2 cb2
dot font cv2 dot
font plane
and then let's say for the thickness or
this is the scale let's put it as three
and then we have okay we need to go back
then we have the color two five five
uh let's keep it blue
yeah and then we will write
three this is the thickness so if we run
this
we should have here p time
p times equals to zero
so if we run this we should have our
frame rate
there we go
so that is quite good
okay so next we have the frame rate we
have the display
now we are going to do the actual part
of all of these
steps so first of all we have to get the
landmarks to get the landmarks we have
to declare here
the detector we have to create the
object so detector
is equals to hdm
dot hand detector and inside that
do we need to add something we can add
for example the maximum hands
because we are only expecting one hand
so we can write here one
and the rest we can keep same
then here we are going to go down and we
are going to write
that our image image
is equals to detector dot
find hands not fingers up
find hands find
hands and then we
are going to find the
positions of these hands so we are going
to write here lm list
and the bounding box so this is
something that we added in our previous
project
and we will write here detector detector
dot find position
i think the spellings detector
find position and then we will
write image so we are sending in our
image
and that should detect it and it should
also draw
so let's run this and see if it detects
we have an issue uh finance oh we have
to give
the argument of image my bad
okay so there you go so now we are
detecting
our bounding box and we are detecting
the fingers
and the landmarks as well so that is
pretty good
so we are done with step number one and
now
we will check that if
if our length of our lm
list is not equals to zero
then we are going to get the
tip info so we can actually put this up
here
so here we will write x1 and y1 so these
are the points of the index finger
so we are going to write lm list and we
will write
that it is point number eight and we
want
from we want the element number one
and two so we will write it like this
uh the same thing we will do for our
second finger which is the middle finger
we will write
x2 and y2 and here instead of
8 we will write 12. so this will give us
the coordinates
of our index and middle fingers so
we do not need to draw these at this
point
so we can just print them out if you
want to see
we can print x1 y1 and then
x2 and y2 so we can print those
and we are getting an error x1 y1
not enough values to unpack expect it to
got one why is that
lm list let me check here what is the
issue
this is find position yeah
and this is lm list and
bounding box yes so that should be fine
okay let's print out the lm list first
print lm list
let's check that
yeah we are getting some values and it
seemed fine
[Music]
oh okay my bad should be one
one and colin
okay there you go so now we are getting
the points
there you go so now we are getting all
these points so
for the index finger and the middle
finger
we move them around you can see the
values they change
okay so this is good we are done with
our second parts now we will go on to
the
third part check which fingers are up
now this is
extremely simple because we have already
created a method by the name fingers up
all we have to do is we have to call it
we will write here
detector dot
find uh not find fingers up and we will
store it
in fingers
so we can push this in
and let's print out so print
fingers and we will remove the print
from here
so let's run that
so there you go so all the fingers are
up all of them are
closed one two three
four and five so we are getting these
values
so that is pretty good now let's go to
the next step
which is okay let me push those all of
these in
okay so step number four is only index
finger
moving mode so now we need to check if
only the index finger is up so we will
write here
if if fingers
at 1 which is the index finger
is equals to one and
fingers at two
is equals to zero so this is when the
index finger is up and the middle finger
is down
so this will be moving mode so now we
need to
move our finger uh
no we need to check where our finger is
moving so we get those points and we
send it to the mouse
coordinates okay so first of all what we
will do is
we will write here that we need to
convert
so here we are converting our
coordinates so we will write here that
x3 is equals to
we will write np dot interp we are going
to convert one range to another range
so here we are converting the x one
value
and the initial range is basically from
zero to the
width of our webcam
and then the second range is
from 0 to the
width of the screen but we didn't get
the width of the screen
now i know that my screen is this size
but it could be different for yours
so in order to get the exact value what
we will do is we will go up here
and we will write here that our width of
the screen
and the height of the screen is equals
to
auto pi dot screen
dot size so this will give us the size
of the screen
so if we remove the print from here
and if we remove this statement and all
of this
uh yeah so then we can print this
print w screen and
height screen okay let's run this
and there you go so now you can see it's
telling me it's 9 to
1920 by 1080 so this is the idea now
that we have these values
let's comment this now that we have
these values we'll go back here
and
we are going to continue
that it is from 0 to the width
of the screen so the same thing we will
do
with the height we will copy this and we
will write here y3
and then we will write here y1 and then
we will write here
height and then height
so this is the idea so these are the
points
that now we have converted and now we
will
send this value to the mouse we will
smoothen these values but we will do
that later on
first we need to see what is the
original result and then we can convert
it
so here we are going to write auto pi
dot
mo mouse dot move
and then we are going to write that
our x3 and our y3
are our coordinates
so let's try this and see what happens
so you can see my mouse here if i bring
in my hand
and this is my index finger and now you
can see it is moving but the problem is
when i'm going to the right it's going
to the left
so this is very annoying and it is very
it's not intuitive so what we will do is
we will flip it
in order to flip it we just need to flip
the width so what we will say is
we will say that whatever the width of
the screen is
screen is minus this
so now if i go to the right it should go
to the right
so the image here will be flipped but in
reality i'm moving to the right
and the mouse is also moving to the
right now if i move to the left
the mouse is also moving to the left
so this should be easier to work with
so that is good uh what we can do
is we can draw a circle so that we know
that we are what you call moving the
mouse so here we can write
cv2 dot circle and we will write
image and then we are going to write x1
and y1 so we want to draw on that
and let's say 15 is the radius and the
color
is purple and
then we will write cb2 dot filled cv2
dot
filled
there we go so let's run that
yeah so now whenever we are in moving
mode
then it will show us this big circle
so that we know that we are in moving
mode
okay so this is good
so now one of the issues here is that
when i am moving when i'm moving
i can go up very easily it's not that
bad
uh it flickers at the top much more than
in the center
but i can go there but if i want to go
down it's very hard because
the hand is not detected properly
again if i move down you can see it's
not detecting property and i'm unable to
go down
so what we can do is we can set a region
where
we want to detect the movement instead
of the whole
image size we can set a particular range
so how can we do that
first of all let's create that range so
we will write here cv2 dot
rectangle and we will set in our image
and then we are going to call this let's
say
frame so this will be a certain value
for example
100 or 200 something like that so we
will call it
frame reduction
and we will also again call it frame
reduction so we can go up and we can
declare it here frame reduction is
equals to let's say 100
so we will write here this is basically
frame
reduction reduction
okay so that should be good
now once we have the frame reduction
what we can do is
now we need to give in the second value
so this is the initial value
now we need to give the diagonal points
so we will write here that the width of
the cam
minus the frame r and
then the second point will be
the height of the camera minus
frame r then we will given the color 255
0
and 255 and then we will give in the
thickness so this will draw a rectangle
so let's try that so whenever
we are in it's not drawing anything oh
it is
yeah whenever we are in okay um
okay maybe we nee we need to put this
outside
so we can put it outside here
because we won't always want to see it
whenever we have the hand in
we want to see it so now you can see we
have
our box now the idea here is that when i
reach the top
of this rectangle it should
be the mouse should be at the top of my
screen and when i
reach the bottom of this it should be at
the bottom of the screen
so and same thing for the corners if i
am moving at this corner it should be at
the corner but now you can see it is not
at the corner
so again you can adjust these values up
and down we will keep it in the center
for now
but later on if you want to you can
adjust so how can you reflect this
on our x3 and y3 so how can you change
these values
so all you have to do is it's very
simple instead of zero
you will write here frame r
you'll write here frame r and here
you are going to write width of the cam
minus frame r
and height of the cam minus frame r
that's it so now
your values should reflect properly
so here if i have my finger at the
top right corner you can see it reaches
the top right corner
if i have it on the other side you can
see it's reaching the top
and now if i go back and i go down you
can see it reaches down
so we are having some issues as well
it's going out of bounds
uh we can fix those issues later uh what
we can do is we can push this
up as well a little bit so that it is
easier for our fingers to move around
but we can do that later we can move on
to the next step which is to detect the
click
okay so then we are going to
detect the click so here
we have to check if both the index and
middle fingers are up
so we are going to copy this part
and we are going to paste it here and we
will write
one and one so if both of them
are up then we need to find the length
of
uh between our fingers so what we will
do here is we will write
that our detector dot find distance
dot find distance between
which points point number eight and
point number twelve
so uh these are the landmark ids so
landmark
eight and landmark 12 and then we will
write
image then it will unpack the values of
length and
then the image and then the
what did i do here it should be comma
and then
we also get a bunch of info that we are
going to ignore
so the main thing that we need is the
length so we need to know
what is the distance between these two
fingers so what we can do is we can
write here print
length and let's try it
so when we are in our detection mode it
is giving us the length
and it is telling us there is a good
indication because
it actually gives a center point as well
and it draws a line in between
so that is pretty good
okay so what we can do next is we can
check
if the length is below a certain value
then we will detect it as a click
but we need to define that threshold
so we are going to go back
and let's try it out so here it should
be open here it should be closed
so i can see it's around 30 something
so if it's less than 40 maybe
yeah okay so we can say if it's around
less than 40 then it is detected as a
click
uh you can do a normalization here as
well but that will be
quite a detail so we are not going to go
into that
so we will write here length is less
than 40
then we are going to cv2
dot circle we are going to draw the same
circle
that we had drawn here but this time we
are going to draw it in green
so we have the detection that it has
been clicked
so let's try that so here
there you go
um we could draw it to the center one as
well
it will look better okay how can we do
that basically this is the information
we are getting
for the line so we can write here info
line
or we can write line info
and then based on this line info if we
go to
our fine distance you can see
cx and cy are the last elements so
this is the fourth and this is the fifth
so we will write here
this is the fourth
and this here is the fifth
push it down okay
so let's run this and hopefully this
time
the center one will be green there you
go
so now it looks a little bit better so
that's good
okay so what is next now we actually
need to click
so rather than just changing it to green
we need to click and the clicking part
is way easier than you think
uh and that is auto pi dot
mouse dot click and that's it
so now it should click uh by the way
these two we are
already uh doing so we should write here
that we are checking the distance here
and then
we are clicking the mouse if the
distance is short
over here so that's the idea
okay so let's try it so what i will do
is i will try to click
and minimize this this part here so
here is my finger and if i move around
and i click
you can see it's shaking a lot
yeah it clicked there you go it click
again
but as you can see it shakes a lot so
this is a very big problem
which is not allowing us to use this
properly
so what can we do as i mentioned before
if we go up here we can smoothen the
values
so how can we smooth in the values so
what we can do is
instead of sending in exactly the same
value that
for example if it goes from 0 to 100
instead of saying go to 100 directly
we will dilute it a little bit so we
will smoothen it
we will reduce its value so it goes step
by step
so what we can do is first of all we are
going to create a value
called smooth
the ning
is equals to let's say five
so this is a random value that i've
chosen uh later on we can see what is
the effect
okay so now what we will do is we will
uh we need to also create
two variables so what we will do is we
will write here
in fact we need to create more than two
variables
so we should separate the variable
declarations here
yeah that should be fine okay so what we
will do is we will say that our previous
location
we will call it previous location of x
and the previous location of y is equals
to
0 0 and the current location of
x location of
x and the current location
of y so again these will be 0 and 0.
so what we will do is what did i do here
so what we will do is we will use these
values
and we will update them each iteration
to smoothen our mouse
so here we are going to go here now
instead of x3
and y3 we are going to send in the
smoothen values
of current location and we will update
our previous location
so how can we do that we will write here
that
our current location of x is equals to
our previous location of x plus
our x3
minus our previous location of x
divided by the smoothing value
so whatever the value is we will divide
it by that and the same thing
we will do with our y value
so we can write here y you can multiply
with this as well
you can multiply smoothing as well then
you will have to go into points
so 0.1 0.2 or you can divide
and keep it whole numbers it's up to you
so we write here y three and then we
will write
y and then we will write that's it okay
so
then we will just send in our
x value and y value instead of
x three and y three and
then we will just update these values
once we have
uh use them so we will write here
previous
location x and previous location y
is equals to current location x
okay let's put y first current location
uh current location
x okay so that is the idea
now uh let's put a very dramatic value
let's say 20 and let's run it
so now you will see if i move it around
you see it
is quite smooth but it is
quite slow so we need to find
you see when i stop it takes a while to
stop
so what we need to do is we need to find
a good balance
so let's try five
so i like this it moves nicely and it
stops
it doesn't shake a lot there you go i
can click as well
there you go and
let's click on the minimize there you go
so yeah
that looks good uh let's try
10.
uh 10 is good but it's a little bit
slower
yeah it's hard to stop at that point
yeah
10 is a little bit fast it is a little
bit slower
so maybe seven
yeah this one is better there you go i
can do that
i can go to this one i can click on this
one
and this one again there you go
so it is pretty good
so that is quite nice
so that is pretty much it as you can see
it works quite well
and we broke it down into different
steps and
when you go and try to solve each of
these steps
it becomes very easy to get a solution
and all of this is possible thanks to
our hand tracking module that we created
earlier
if we don't do that then it will be
quite difficult
and it will take quite a lot of time to
actually create such a project
but as you can see it was quite easy and
quite simple
what we achieved in this short amount of
time
so this is it for today's video i hope
you have learned something new
if you like the video give it a thumbs
up and don't forget to subscribe
and i will see you in the next one
you